- What kind of wave form
are we making today?
(electric guitar sound)
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Bah, bah, bah, bah, bah,
bah, bah, bah, bah, bah.
- Let's make a penis wave form.
- Dude.
(upbeat music)
- Well, this is like "Squid Game".
- What?
- No, it's not.
- Says a lot about society.
- You can't just say
something is like something.
- Just say everything
is like "Squid Game".
That's like human now.
That's what makes me laugh.
- What's the meme?
I don't get the meme.
- I don't know.
- What's the punchline?
- That's the point.
It's like poo poo stinky.
- It's like an anti-joke.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah.
- Well, this says a lot about society.
- It says a lot about society,
when I have to explain an anti-joke.
- It says a lot about society.
- You just want to say it.
I just want to see the
context of this fucking meme.
- There is no context.
It's just like Peter Griffin,
just like leaning over in black and white.
And his like, "This says
a lot about society."
- This does say a lot about society.
- That has become a meme.
- Says a lot about society.
- I don't know why it's become a meme.
But I'll be bored of it by
the time this episode airs.
- Like, there are some
anti-jokes that I get,
and then there are some that are just,
this isn't even bass boosted.
How can you find it funny?
- Give it a day and
you'll be laughing, I bet.
- Welcome society to another
episode of "Trash Taste."
- For fucks sake Joey.
- It says a lot when they have to open
a "Trash Taste" episode like that.
- It says a lot.
- It does say.
I don't think it says enough.
- I am society member number one
with two more members of society.
Hello.
- Hello.
- Hello, hello.
You know what says a lot about society?
The fact that we don't
watch anime anymore.
- See, see, now you're
laughing at the joke.
See, now you're laughing at the joke.
- I'm just laughing at how
shit the fucking segway was.
- Did you just like
speed run, titular title.
- Yes, I think so.
I think so.
Okay, for once we gotten a
pretty interesting discussion
before we started turning on
the cameras and we were like-
- We're like, "Wait."
- ... "Wait."
- "Sh, save it for the episode."
- I think we should turn on the cameras
before we start-
- Yeah, true.
- ...talking.
- But instead we're talking about society.
- I can't believe we had a conversation,
and didn't try to monetize it.
- Yeah, right?
- What the fuck?
- Fuck.
- I just don't talk
unless the camera is on.
- I'm a professional podcaster.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I was basically ranting how,
I don't watch anime nowadays.
- I mean, you guys know that anyway.
- That's not a revelation.
- [Joey] No.
- But I think that a lot of people
think it just because like
I've fallen out of it.
It's not that.
It's just like,
I find so much anime,
just so goddamn boring now.
- I just find,
it's not even about it being boring.
It's just redundant.
I just feel like it really
says a lot about society.
- Oh my God.
See, he laughed, see liked the meme.
Okay, why does it say a
lot about society, Joey?
I want to hear your explanation.
- It's just, he was going
to say, he was going to say,
it says a lot about anime.
- I was going to say, "It
really says a lot about anime."
But then the moment I said,
"It really says a lot."
It just like, it was like, it was like.
- That was like the
100% unintentional pun.
- I support this, okay, go on, go on.
- It really says a lot about anime,
when all it takes is for
me to read a synopsis.
- Yeah.
- And I could probably
tell you with 90% accuracy
what the first three
episodes of that anime
is going to be about.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Not even in like,
an arty farty general type of
way, like in a detailed way.
- Yeah, I would like to preface,
since we have to preface every argument.
You know, there's always
like one or two shows
that are good.
- [Joey] Yes.
- I think that are entertaining.
- [Joey] Of course.
- No, all anime sucks.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But like there is just
so much like mediocre stuff
that is so uninspired,
and just rehashing of
what we've seen before.
Just kind of jumping off
successful characters,
and premises we've had before.
I was talking to Joe earlier, I was like,
there's so many characters now,
I feel like I've watched so many anime.
Like, I get the power fantasy ones, right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But like,
I understand that the point is,
is that they went to be all powerful,
and they can't fuck up.
- Yeah.
- But like, is that always that fun?
Like, is it always like, great?
Like sometimes I'm like,
can you have like a flaw or something.
Like something that
makes you a little human.
- So that, I'm not like bored
out of my mind watching you.
- No.
- Like, Saitama is bold, right?
- Yeah.
- That's flawed.
- That's a flawed.
- That's a flaw in itself.
- I can relate, man.
- No, I get it.
But that's the problem, right?
Is that I think the reason
why power fantasies are just,
they make the most like,
"Perfect main characters,"
is because it, if they had flaws,
it would completely go against
the point of it being a power fantasy.
It's like, why would I want to self insert
myself into this all powerful character,
if this character,
that is supposed to be
the better version of me
also makes mistakes, right?
I get that.
But at the same time it's like,
"Okay, that's fine, if
you're self inserting,
but not every person who
watches shows like that
wants to self insert."
They just want to watch a
character that is completely
independent from them,
go through this adventure
or whatever, right?
But I don't know.
- I mean,
I feel like I'm like the
spokesperson for like that-
- Go on, go on go on.
- ...that kind of anime.
And I'm just like, yeah.
I completely recognize that.
The problem with anime nowadays is that,
one, there is so much of it.
And number two,
a lot of it is what I just
call "Cold Disposable Shows."
- Right.
- Where,
it's just not even like a show anymore.
- Yeah.
- It's just content.
It's just something you consume, right.
So, that's how I view
a lot of Isekai, right.
The reason I watch a lot of Isekai,
is because it's exactly the same thing.
I'm not going to remember most of them,
but I get the same kind of experience.
It's the same region as
what I see people watching,
"Trash TV shows" for,
like trash reality shows.
Like, you know what
you're getting with say,
"Kitchen Nightmares" or "Hell's Kitchen,"
or, something along those lines,
where it's just a repeatable format.
Gordon Ramsey comes to a restaurant,
and surprise, surprise
the restaurant sucks.
- But that's why I also don't
watch shows like that, either.
They're the exact same.
- It's like a massive market.
- [Joey] Yeah, absolutely.
- I agree.
In some senses, but
then it also feels like,
especially Isekai is just like, so inbred.
You know what I mean?
It's like they don't
take from anything else.
- Yeah.
- They just keep fucking.
- Incest.
They just keep having in with these shows.
- It is incentious.
- Where is the incest card?
- But like these shows
when I'm watching them,
it just feels like,
the shows aren't trying to
take from anything interesting.
- They're all just taking
from the successful show
in their own category.
- Yeah.
- Right?
So, I kind of feel like
I'm just losing my mind,
watching these shows where like,
no one even tries to do anything
even remotely different.
- Yeah.
It's the issue of like anime
that is inspired by anime.
Like Isekai as a genre,
is basically just like a self sucking,
like circle where,
is it ouroboros where-
- [Joey] Yeah, ouroboros.
- ...it's like the fucking
snake eating itself.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, it is.
- It is an ouroboros.
And that's why, again, like
it just feels derivative.
You watch a show that
is supposedly brand new.
- And I just read through
the synopsis and I go,
I feel like I've seen
this show about 10 times.
- I'm glad that you say that, sorry Garnt.
- Yeah.
- Just because I feel like
if I was just saying that,
I feel like some people might argue
there's a language difference going on
where I can't fully understand
the nuance of these characters.
- Like, every time I go
to a bookstore, right.
And I'm trying to find something new,
and I go over to the Light Novel section.
Because I always want
to say like, you know,
what's popular.
- [Garnt] What's popping.
What's popping, right?
- Because I'm just curious.
It's like, okay,
maybe there's like a
change or something, right.
I go over and I see all these new titles
I've never heard of.
And I just look at the title
and I look at the covers,
and I go,
"How is this title and cover
any different to the one next to it?"
- [Connor] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Like it doesn't.
They just look like
spinoffs of each other.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Just from the feel,
and even going through the synopsis,
I just think to myself,
it's like this book right here,
was inspired by the
book sitting next to it,
and vice versa.
There's no difference.
It's just a reskin of the same thing.
So, every time, I do like
the "What Will I Be Watching,"
which is where, you know, I
go to the next season, right.
- Biggest lie of the century.
- Exactly,
but nowadays the reason why
I still continue that show
on my channel,
it's not because I actually sit through,
and watch all the anime I talk about,
it so that I can hopefully
find that one show,
that would actually be non derivative,
and somewhat interesting for
me to actually go and watch.
- Which is why I feel
like the Isekai genre
right now especially,
like, the show that I'm
like been bigging up so much
is "Mushoku Tensei".
- Yeah.
It's the Isekai that basically started,
the whole Isekai Light
Novel trend in terms of,
this is the one series that,
from what I can see has like,
this is the one progenitor
for all the tropes,
or a lot of the tropes that you've seen,
and like watching the anime adaptation,
which is airing right now.
It's just a really fucking good show.
I'm not saying it's a
good show for an Isekai.
It's just a really good show.
- It's a great fucking fantasy.
- So, I've started
watching "Mushoku Tensei".
I'm like halfway through the first season,
because it's season two right now, right.
- Yeah, it's season two right now, yeah.
- So, I started watching the first season
just because Garnt and a bunch
of other people were like,
"Oh, this is the one that started it all."
- Yeah.
- And I was like,
"Bet, I'll check it out."
And yeah, I completely agree.
You can see where all of
the origins of what made
the Isekai genre was so great came from.
Yeah, as you said, it's just a good show.
- Like with so many Isekai,
and so many of these
disposable anime nowadays,
it's like the first episode airs,
and the anime is like,
"You know how it is, you know how it is.
We don't need to explain shit.
We don't need to like build up
the world or the characters,
you know, this character
archetype, you know, this world."
I remember watching the first
episode of "Mushoku Tensei".
And they spent like a whole episode
where they're building up this character,
and how he dies,
and how he's a baby,
and how he like wakes up in this world.
And he's just like figuring out the world,
even though in every other Isekai,
they're just like,
dies, Isekai, it's like five minutes.
- Yeah.
It really says a lot when
I've watched some Isekai.
Shut up.
- It really says a lot of Isekai.
- It really says a lot
about Isekai society.
When I start up a show, just
the generic Isekai show,
just wanting to see what it is.
And I think I'm watching episode one,
but it feels like I'm
halfway through the season.
- Just because they just
assume you already know
all these tropes.
- And it's like,
are you not going to try and make it
unique or interesting,
or explain anything about the world?
Do you just assume that
everyone who watches the show
already has seen the show
in some of the forms?
- Because sometimes you
also watch an anime as well,
where you can tell that the
people behind this like,
put a lot of effort into this.
There's like,
that extra tinge,
that extra sparkle that, you know.
- You can say when an anime
is just like clearly thrown together.
- Like, from "Mushoku Tensei" for example,
like, you know with a lot
of anime that they speak.
Where the character speak
a different language,
and they just don't even bother.
And they translate it back into Japanese,
even though the characters are not
technically speaking Japanese.
- I hate that.
- Yeah.
So, in "Mushoku Tensei",
they didn't just make up one language.
They made up two separate,
fantasy made up languages for this show,
which is used in the show.
And I've never seen that
with any other anime,
especially not any other
Isekai fantasy anime,
where the characters are actually speaking
to like the fantasy characters
in their own language,
which is just a made up Isekai language,
or made up fantasy language,
and then different species
have different languages.
So, they literally have just
made up two separate languages.
I'm just like,
this is the shit that not
like everyone will appreciate,
but this is one big indicator that
the people producing these
show really gives a shit.
- Shit like Welsh or something.
- Yeah.
It's like Icelandic.
- But they made this shit up.
It's insane.
- Because you want "Vinland Saga", right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, so, do you
remember that scene where
I think it was like,
it wasn't Askeladd,
but it was Thorfinn talking
to some French people
with also English people there,
and Thorfinn is also from Scandinavian,
whatever the Scandinavian languages is,
but they were all speaking
Japanese to each other.
- Yeah, that was really boring.
I really hated it.
- Yeah.
And they were all speaking Japanese
telling each other how
they can't understand
what each other are saying.
- Yeah.
- Even though they were
all speaking Japanese.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And I was like,
this is "Vinland Saga",
fucking amazing, amazing anime,
but the little things like that
are just like immersion breaking.
- Yeah, it really does make a difference.
And that's what I would argue
some of the greatest
fantasy stories out there
is what made it so in.
I mean like, could you imagine,
if you will watching
fucking Lord of the rings.
- And just Elven, wasn't
just spoken at all.
And like, every character
is speaking to the Elvens
in English.
- Like that one could be
such immersion breaking.
And it would also just completely
ruin the world building.
- Right, even like Netflix dramas, right.
They'll sometimes have
like four or five language,
different casts and
everything all on site.
And that's like something
that I always get.
Like I appreciate a fuck ton.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I love that.
- But in anime it just feels like
that never ever happens.
- [Joey] Right.
- I know it's happened a few times.
I can't remember which ones.
I Know it has,
but it has just never rarely happens.
- Yeah, it just sucks this well, though.
I feel the main reason why a lot of anime
just opt to not do that
is just because they think,
"Oh, the audience isn't
going to be fucked."
- Right.
- I think most
in an ideal world they
would like to do it,
but it's just,
there's so much anime being made now
there are so much being made
under like a big time crunch.
- [Joey] That is true as well.
- I wonder with the whole anime thing.
Is it like a natural thing?
If me as an anime fan,
who's watched anime for a very long time,
to get bored of anime?
Is it a natural occurrence?
- I think so.
- Or is it that I'm being picky?
I don't know.
- Would you say you're
growing out of anime?
- I don't think am growing out.
- Dare I say.
- Well, this says a lot about society.
- It does say a lot about society, Joey.
One thing that says a lot about society.
I feel like a lot of anime,
a lot of anime do this is kind of like
disguise of like, "We're not for kids,"
but then you watch it,
and you watch the character
dialogue and how they talk.
And you're like only a
teenager would think like,
this is how people talk to each other.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- This is not like a real conversation.
That's where like, you know,
I hate to use a Western example,
but like "Castlevania,"
like the script in "Castlevania"
was so goddamn good.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- The character interactions
in "Castlevania" was so good.
Like I wanted to know more
about these characters.
Every time they spoke,
even the ones I didn't like.
- [Joey] I agree.
- Yeah.
- Every character when
they spoke about anything
was anime fucking delight.
But in anime it's always just like,
it's got to serve the plot if it doesn't,
it's all about tits or funny.
I don't know, like me being a peep.
And like I was saying earlier as well,
another thing I really dislike, right?
Lelouch is like,
anime's favorite character.
And it really fucking shows.
Because like there's so many characters
that are like Lelouch, right.
But like fail to see,
what made Lelouch so good, right?
- It's like diet Lelouch.
- Lelouch is good to me.
- What did make Lelouch good then?
- One, right?
First of all, you get lured in with this,
"Oh my God, he's a genius," right?
- Right.
- That he's cool.
He's sick, bro.
- Yeah.
- He's strong.
And then you realize he's a psychopath,
and that he's scared as well.
Like anyone else in this world.
- Yeah.
- And the thing that I find that a lot of,
and you know, even like Light, right?
Light in Death Note.
Light makes mistakes.
- Yeah.
- Light worries, Light panics,
Light freaks out, right?
Like with a lot of these
power fantasy shows
where they try and make a character
that like resembles or takes from that.
I find that most of
the time it's so boring
because there's absolutely no
other character trait to them.
Maybe the one thing they're sad about
is like the Saitama thing where like,
"I'm so strong, it's boring."
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But even then the way
that One Punch Man does it,
is really tasteful.
I don't even know how to describe how.
- It's because the show
doesn't take itself seriously.
- Right, Saitama does it in a way
that's kind of like really
fun and really playful,
that doesn't really take itself too much.
But anytime I watched
these power fantasy shows,
I feel like my brain is rotting.
Like I'm watching it,
and I'm just like,
I'd rather watch Big Ed have
like some mental breakdown,
on 90 Day Fiance.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Like I don't know how to put it.
Like, I feel like animate
treats me like I'm stupid,
and I hate that.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- A lot of anime shows
do check the audience
like they're stupid.
- Yeah, I hate it.
- Maybe because a lot of them are.
- Jojo,
assumes I'm stupid,
and then doesn't give a
fuck and carries on any way.
Like Jojo doesn't care.
It's fucking stupid.
But I love it.
- Yeah, I mean, I was
telling these boys earlier
that I've recently had
to start watching anime,
or like two 2 times
speed or 1.5 times speed.
- Because 1 time speed is so boring.
- Which is like fucking insane to me.
And I don't watch it at
that point for enjoyment.
- It's just to consume, right?
- It's just for like my seasonal videos
where I do have to watch everything.
I remember it got to a point
like two, three years ago
where you look at the seasonal
chart and you're like,
"If I watched everything on this chart,
I literally be watching
two seasons worth of anime
every week,
just to keep up with
every show being aired."
- I'm sorry to go on.
- Yeah.
It's just impossible to actually consume,
or watch everything coming out now.
That's why a lot of it's just
disposable shit, honestly.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Go on.
- No, I was about to say, you know,
that's I guess like one
of the biggest criticisms
I get about like Joey doesn't watch anime.
It's like, yeah, because I can't.
There's so much shit out there.
So much of it is so derivative
that I would dead ass rather go back,
and watch shows that I didn't get to watch
all those years ago,
or shows that came out before
I was even born, right?
I'd much rather spend the time on that
there is in fact less of a
selection all those years ago
than there is every single year,
like new shows coming out, right.
- I don't know, like I'm
limited with my time, right?
I don't want to spend,
fucking you know, 20
hours of the day watching-
- [Connor] Yeah, fuck that.
- ... anime bunch of
shit that I'm not going
to remember next week
because it's so fucking
mediocre, and redundant.
- You always do like Isekais.
You do the anime, the
seasonal anime videos, right?
- Yeah.
- And like, I'm going to watch them.
So, you know.
- Okay, okay.
- I'm watching, I watch them.
And I feel like after
I've watched them now,
you'll always like talk about
a show or two that sounds amazing.
And then I'll never hear you
ever mentioned ever again.
What's up with that?
- What's up with that?
Well, I talk about shows
that have potential, right.
- Okay.
- And a lot of them might not,
might not say pan out and some of them do.
- They might fizzle out.
- Yeah, they might fizzle out.
That's why I do like my
end of year videos as well,
which is just like,
okay, these are the shows
that I actually stuck with,
because they're okay.
So, there are some good
shows that air every season,
but then there are some shows
that I feel are just the best
and are best consumed via anime, right.
There are some shows that
have interesting concepts
that I call like Manga
recommendation shows,
which is I watched like
the first two episodes.
I'm like, this is really interesting,
but like, you know what,
it's just like an average adaptation.
So, what happens is I just
go off and read the Manga,
and I'm like, "Cool.
I don't need to watch the anime anymore."
- I have a much better experience
reading the Manga, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That does happened?
- When you just watch a
show and you're just like,
I can get this exact same
experience, just reading Manga.
And then you do.
And then you're like, great.
The seasonal anime did its job
as a Manga recommendation channel.
- It's like something about reading Manga,
that is way more palatable
for shitty shows.
- Yeah.
- I don't know why,
I think when these
characters are so boring,
because I can just speed run through
their boring ass dialogue,
and it's like way more enjoyable.
- Well, I think it's
because there are more
like places or more factors in anime
that leave for a larger room for error.
Because the only thing you
have to really worry about
with a Manga is the dialogue
and the artwork and the story.
But whereas with anime,
you have things like voice
acting to worry about.
You have things like
sequencing to worry about,
you have things, animation
and fucking music.
And like there's all these
other factors that could make
that show look and feel way more mediocre
than the core of the show.
- Yeah, which is why like,
I rarely read Manga that
hasn't been released yet
because I do feel even now
that I'm reading more Manga,
that if there's a good anime adaptation,
it's just untouched.
- [Joey] Yeah.
Like a good anime
adaptation of a good Manga,
fucking untouched.
I'd rather experience the
anime first time hand,
which is why when these
anime do get released,
and I see one or two episodes,
that's all I need some see to be like,
"Okay, this is going to
be a mediocre adaptation.
I'm just going to read the Manga."
There's so many shows right now,
which I feel like you
can just read the Manga,
and you'll be completely fine with.
But they're all just like
those one or two gems
every season, or like most seasons
where you're just like,
"Okay, this is a banger.
I'm glad anime exists because
of these fucking shows."
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- True.
Like "Attack on Titan"
is one of those, right?
- Oh, yeah, 100%, I
love "Attack on Titan".
- I can not read the Manga
for "Attack on Titan."
- Yeah.
- I refuse to read it.
I hope we're not spoiling this.
Not to demerit anyone
who does read the Manga,
but I just feel like
"Attack on Titan" anime
is the best way to like
experience that story.
- [Joey] I agree.
- I can't imagine getting like
the emotional highs I did
with the story without having
watched it in the anime first.
- Yeah, and again,
it's because I feel that because
of the added factors that
make an anime different from a Manga,
like the animation,
the voice acting the music.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- In the case with the "Attack on Titan,"
all of those were fucking amazing.
So, it just heightened.
- Yeah, don't get angry about the anime.
- But that's the thing,
it's like those like anime only factors
only heightened an already
great story and characters.
- [Garnt] Yeah, exactly.
- So, that's why I feel you just get
a better experience with the anime.
But a lot of anime
adaptations can't do that.
In fact, they pull it down sometimes.
- Yeah, exactly.
Which is why, like, I there's
some shows where like,
I know it's going to like
slap like "Chainsaw Man."
- [Joey] Yeah.
- That's one show where I'm
like, I could read the Manga.
Because I know it's a
fucking amazing Manga.
- Yeah, I don't want to, go on.
- But I want to wait.
I want to wait for the anime adaptation.
- See, but that's good though
that you guys are waiting
because in case it sucks,
you have a great Manga to look forward to.
- True, true.
- So, it's just a win for you guys, right?
For me, it's like,
I've already read the
Manga multiple times now.
So, like I'm scared that my experience
could go really far down,
or it could just keep getting better.
Like, I'm at a gambling stage right now.
For you guys it's like, I
don't care what the plot is,
I'm taking fucking taking over the Manga.
- I want to like anime, I do.
I want to watch.
I want to watch more, man.
I really do, and I feel bad that like.
- I feel like part of the
reason you don't watch more
is because it's like harder
for you to watch more now
living in Japan, right?
- That too.
- Because you have to go out of your away.
Because everything you've
watched is on Netflix now.
- Yeah.
A big thing for me with watching stuff
is like being comfortable.
Like I don't want to watch
something at my computer desk.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I do not want to do that.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And I like to Chromecast
things as we all know.
I like to Chromecast things.
And I mean, I can do with anime.
It's just a lot more annoying to do it.
You know, Control doesn't work in Japan.
And so you've to get
through a lot of layers,
and Chromecast doesn't work
with VPNs unless you have like,
it's a whole fucking mess.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- But there are obviously there's ways.
But,
it a pain in the ass.
And Netflix is a very like hassle free.
I don't have to think.
Everything just works nicely.
I know that's so, normie
of me, I know that's normie
but it works.
- No, but like, I've been slowly starting
to feel the same way.
- Because you value your time
and mild frustration is like,
my house could burn down,
whatever we'll deal with it.
That's a big problem, right.
I'll be devastated.
But there's something about
mild annoyances that get to me
on an emotional level way
more than like devastated.
- Are you're saying that
your house burning down
is a mild inconvenience.
- Yeah.
- You said your house burning down
like it was a mild annoyance.
- Both.
If my house burnt down, we'll be fine.
- Why did it sound like
your house burning down
is the same equivalent to
like, "Oh, I ran out of milk."
- I have a very good insurance
policy, okay, Joey, I know.
I mean like something about like massive,
like really big annoying things happen.
I don't know why it's like
easier for me to deal with,
but like really annoying little things
that like you can't quite complain about.
And it's not big enough to be a problem.
- Except on this podcast.
- It's just always annoying.
- Yeah, except on this podcast.
It's just a little bit annoying.
- Yeah, that's why for me,
if there's one thing that
will get me frustrated
every single fucking
time without question,
it's just dealing with
small issues in tech.
- Yeah.
- It kills everything for me.
- I think that annoys me more than like,
I'm not a very like, ragey angry person,
but that is one thing
that will get me pissed off every time.
- Yeah.
- By the way, if you haven't noticed
the lighting is a little bit different
because our WiFi isn't working
in this office right now.
- Oh, yeah, speaking of techy shit.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You just reminded me,
and like having to try and fucking debug,
and deal with the WiFi
issues and this office,
which we haven't fucking figured
out what the issue is yet.
- Has just like put me in
this like rage inducing
fucking coma, I swear to God.
- That's why though like,
my PC set up at home,
is like quite complicated.
There's a lot of stuff.
A lot of moving things.
A lot of wires.
I have like two externally
powered USB ports
that are all full.
I have like 15 plugs taken out.
Like this shit isn't like
a fire hazard problem,
I don't even know.
- Are you running the fucking
White House from your place?
- When one thing goes wrong,
it like fucks everything up.
I have to deal with so many
tech issues for like streaming
or making YouTube videos or anything.
- I just don't want to
deal with tech issues,
when I want to relax.
It brings me back into work.
- This brings me back
into my engineering phase,
where you turn on something,
you turn on a device and
something doesn't work.
Or you write a piece of code
and something doesn't work.
It doesn't render out correctly.
And you're just like,
"Great, so how do I figure
out what's going on?"
And you just have to go through everything
one by one by one.
I remember,
because since I've been trying
to set up my new office,
and do like a proper streaming
set up and everything
like that, I'm just like, "Wow."
I can see why people complain
about cable management.
Because before when I moved to Japan,
I was just like one computer,
two monitors, speakers done.
Don't care about streaming.
Don't care about that shit.
Now we're like doing all
sorts of different things.
You've got to worry about lighting.
You're worried about all
these different plugs.
You've got to worry about,
you know, the GoXLR,
all this, like, there's
so many different devices
on our desk now.
And as I was setting up.
I overestimated how fast
it would take to like set
everything up in a neat package, right?
- It took me like four days.
- So, like I set everything up.
I'm just like,
"Okay, let's like cable
manage this entire thing."
Spend the entire day trying to like
cable manage everything, super neatly,
setting up all my devices.
So, they are like optimally placed.
Set everything up, do
it for an entire day.
And then I forget,
that my desk is a standing desk,
and I've been setting it up
during the sitting position.
And so what I did is, I set everything up.
I'm like, "Great," check
my emails, stand up.
- Everything breaks.
- And then the screen
just like turns to black,
and everything falls down.
- I'm like, "oh, my God."
- Yeah.
- And I'm just like maybe
YouTube is overrated.
Maybe streaming is overrated.
- Here the thing,
if people don't tell you about
cable management too, right?
When you, when you put
it all in like one braid,
like you put it all together.
When you want to change one
cable, that shit fucking sucks.
You have to take everything
apart and then find the cable
like between like the
nested, all the shit.
And then you're like, all right.
Maybe being neat is just not worth it.
Maybe I should be fucking messy.
- Yeah, my idea of cable
management in my place,
is just take all of the wires,
and just get them off the ground.
That way the Roomba doesn't
fucking suck up the wires.
It looks clean.
I can easily vacuum under there.
I'm happy about that.
- Yeah, like I streamed
for like the first time
in months yesterday.
- Congratulations.
- For this chess stream,
and pretty much everything that
could go wrong did go wrong
when I pressed the go live button.
So, I set up my stream set up, right?
Set everything up, tested
everything the day before,
because I know what it's like.
I know how temperamental equipment is.
So, I tested everything
before I went to sleep.
Everything was working fine.
I wake up.
I didn't even turn the computer off.
I put it into sleep mode
because I'm just like,
"Don't fucking up the settings.
Don't fucking up the settings."
This is the first time I'm
going live in my new office.
I know something's going to go wrong,
but I hope it doesn't go wrong too bad.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- So, I go live,
I put on the starting screen,
starting soon screen,
everything's going well.
I switched to my camera.
It's black.
And I'm just like, "Oh no, oh fucking no."
And I'm just like, "Okay,"
turn the camera on off.
So, the camera we use is
a DSLR with a cam link,
which is what we use for
"Trash Taste" stream.
- Cam link is just saying that you connect
a camera to a PC basically.
- Yeah, yeah.
So, I try restarting the camera and OBS,
I try turning the camera
physically on and off.
Nothing.
Nothing seems to be working.
And I'm just like,
"Fuck, I think I just need
to restart the computer."
I turned the computer off,
restart the computer.
For some reason, the computer's
not detecting cam link.
It's not detecting the cable.
So I go under.
Keep in mind, the fucking
chat it's just like,
"What the is going on?"
- It's the worst when
it's happening with a chat
getting on your ass about it.
- Look like log on, stream,
it's just like,
this is under like the time crunch of,
I just went live, people
already waiting for me.
I've tweeted this shit out.
- And so I go under the
table and I look out.
At this point, I'm in panic mode.
So, I just take out all
of my cable management,
and everything like just fucking explodes.
There's just like an explosion of wires.
And I have to like,
finding it like one strand of spaghetti,
in this the fucking sea of wires
to what this cam link wire is.
So, I find the cam link wire take it out,
plug it back in it doesn't work.
Take it out, plug it
back into another slot.
It doesn't work.
And I'm just like, "Okay,
well I'm out of options."
So, I go into my storage,
get out like my old Logitech camera.
And I'm like fucked, having to plug this.
- At the webcam.
- Yeah, at this point
10 minutes have passed.
I'm just like, "I might not
even going to have any viewers."
I'm like, "Whatever."
Plug it in, Webcam works.
Thank God.
Go live again.
And then OBS has reset all of my settings.
So,
I go live, you see me on the camera.
No noise.
- Oh, no
And then I realize,
I can't just turn on my mic anymore
because my mic is
plugged through my GoXLR,
which has about 10 different
mic settings on the stream.
So, like, here I am just fucking,
I'm like, you know,
when Homer Simpson is at work,
go through like nuclear breakdown.
He's just like pressing buttons.
That was just me, just like,
"Guys can hear me? Can you hear me?"
This is like the most stressful shit.
I empathize with any streamer
who goes through technical difficulty.
- It's awful.
- I've been there.
I've been there.
- Because there's nothing that
kills an energy of a stream,
not just for the stream itself,
but for like your own energy,
quite like going through
technical difficulties.
- When you stream like crashes
and you like come back,
you lose like half of
viewers, it's so depressing.
It's not that you care about the numbers,
but it's just sad seeing like
you just gutted it in half
by just accidentally like
fucking something up.
- And fucking cam link
it's so temperamental.
I know that like,
it has to go in like a
certain USB port on my PC,
or it doesn't work.
Like that's weird.
I haven't even even figured
out what the issue I had is,
or why the camera just stopped
working all of a sudden?
- For me, it's so weird.
For me it's like,
if I want to like record
something through cam link,
it's like I opened OBS, right?
And then I turn the camera on,
and usually it'll like pop up if it works.
It just doesn't pop up
like 99% of the time.
So, I'm like, "What the fuck?
Turn it off, turn it on.
"Oh, now it works."
Like what the?
There's like a tech
goblin just being like,
"Should I work today? Maybe not."
- Yeah, every time you turn on cam link,
God flips a coin.
Sometimes it lands tails,
and sometimes it lands heads.
- Keep the settings or fuck it up,
"Oh, time to fuck it up," beep.
- Yeah, apparently, even
if I keep the settings,
they still flips a coin.
So, I haven't debugs the problem is yet.
And I just have to like,
hope that God smiles on
me next time I stream,
and nothing goes wrong.
- Yeah,
the thing that's annoying about
like that kind of problems
and like tech and streaming
problems that you can't even
like throw money at the
problem to make it go away.
- [Joey] No.
- Yeah.
You are like, it's you're problem,
and you got to learn how to fix it.
And it's a pain in the ass.
It's so annoying.
I've had like every goddamn
issue under the sun.
It's terrible.
Like, something always breaks.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Of course.
Like, especially now that we've
been doing more live action,
live action content.
- Did you just call it
live action content?
- On camera, I don't know.
- I don't know just content, I don't know.
- I love the live action
adaptation of content.
- I love the live action remake of Gigguk.
- The Netflix live action of Gigguk.
- It's so good.
- "Trash Taste" is just a
live action anime adaptation.
- What are you talking about?
What the fuck are you talking about?
- I have no idea.
This is what happens when
you watch too much anime.
It just fucking botch your mind.
- This says a lot about society.
- Like real life to me
now it's just live action.
That's like,
"Yo, I hang out with
someone on live action."
It's kind of nice.
- He goes outside and looks at the grass,
it's like, "Whoa, look at the graphics."
- I went to the Colombini
live action, bro.
Like, what?
- Yeah.
Went outside, I was like,
"Yo, look at this FPS, man,"
- It's at 144 hz, what is this?
- Supermarkets are just
live action, Amazon.
- But no, it's like, made me realize that
just making content isn't enough anymore.
Just worrying about making
good content is enough anymore
because you have to worry about
so much tech things that I just
never thought about before,
because before it was just
me, a mic and a script.
- Yeah, YouTube is very
friendly with that, right?
- I can barely plugging a
fucking GPU two years ago.
Now, I have to like learn how to like,
do all this like tech shit,
and like deal with cam link.
And like I'm thinking about
getting a second camera,
and I'm just like terrified to even like,
think of the possibilities
of how much that's going to fuck up
my already nice setup.
- You can't use two cam links in one PC.
- Yeah, right.
- You can, you can though.
- Very temperamental there.
- Yeah, see, I'm like
scared to do that now.
So, it's like, fuck what do I do?
- No, because like,
yeah, before it was like,
before my entire YouTube career was,
me a script and an
editing software, right?
And now it's just like,
me, a concept, maybe a script,
and then lighting, camera, audio,
is the light flickering? No.
Okay.
Got to change the ISO settings, no.
I've got to change the frame rate.
Okay, no.
Is the audio?
No, it's peaking.
Why is it peaking?
Because the settings got changed,
and I'm just like, "I just
want to make content."
- This is why people have
production companies.
- They don't want to do it.
It's like impossible to
focus on what you're doing,
worrying about how all the tech works.
- [Joey] Exactly, exactly.
- And by the time all the tech get sorted,
you're just like,
"I've wasted like two hours,
and I haven't even done anything.
There's nothing I can monetize
because I haven't recorded.
Haven't even started recording yet.
What is this?"
- That's the one thing I think
you really gained from being
like YouTube or Twitch or any of shit,
is that my God, do you learn
how to like fucking adapt fast.
- [Joey] Oh, yeah.
- You've got to learn or you're fucked.
- Your MacGyver skills
go through the roof.
- You have to, man.
If you have to kind of person
who panics and calm focus
when shits going wrong,
then a RIP.
- I like to say my
engineering skills have like,
been really useful in terms
of just problem solving.
Because there's so many
small problem solving things
you have to do every time you're on a set,
or you're doing something,
and you're making content
because something inevitably
goes wrong and there is no manual
or playbook about what's
going to go wrong.
But something new is going to go wrong,
and you're going to
figure out how to sort it out on the fly.
- Do you think they'll ever be like,
I remember seeing an article
about this on Japanese Twitter
of Japan was thinking
about like starting like
university courses for like YouTube,
and like online content creators.
- I think maybe.
But I think there's
definitely room for like
someone to be like, "Hey, I'm a guy.
I will come to your house and
set everything up for you,
and tell you how to use it.
And you pay me a lot of money."
- We're actually looking
for that right now.
If someone wants to help us
set up our tool Twitch sets up
in our Trash Taste office,
we were trying to find a specialist.
We actually can.
Like we've had to figure it out ourselves.
And we always get comments
about how junk our set up is,
that's because we made it,
and we don't know what
the fuck we're doing.
- I think it's like a
decent setup for live.
Like it's not perfect,
but I think we just want it
to be like more professional
and it's like impossible
to find someone who's like
knowledgeable about this stuff.
- [Joey] Yeah, exactly.
- And normally if they
are knowledgeable about
broadcasting, they're not on Twitch then,
they don't know like
an actual TV and shows.
- But like wouldn't it
be interesting with like,
10, 20 years down the road,
if YouTube just keeps
going up and up and up,
that I don't know,
maybe like our kids
will end up being like,
"So what, university degree
you going to go into son?"
It's like, "I'm going to go
into YouTube and Twitch."
- I mean, the way YouTube is evolving now,
is that the quality of
content just keeps increasing.
It's getting harder and harder
to compete with the larger creators
because the barrier of entry
is just so much higher now.
Like even talking about,
an anime podcast, which
is what we started.
Well,
we put in like thousands
and thousands of dollars
just to get the basic
setup in our old studio.
And now we've like,
we have gone as professional as we can be,
but that was like,
after having like a surprise success
with what we were able to do.
But before that it was like a
lot of money that we invested,
and we didn't know if it was
going to turn into anything,
- Yeah, we were in the red
for a while, that's the truth.
Thank God.
- Yeah, so, now I just think,
well, if you're a new content creator,
and you're trying to make a podcast,
or compete with some of the content
that's is already established
by a lot of larger creators,
there's so much you have to do.
There's so much you have to worry about,
and it's getting harder and harder to,
not only distinguish
yourself but make content,
which for the average viewer
they feel is like of a high
enough production level.
- It's about like doing
what's in your means, right?
Like, I've had friends who are like,
"Oh, I want to do this
thing and this thing,"
it's like, "Yeah, well that's good.
But like, you don't have the
ability to do that right now.
So, like scale it down."
Like Mr. Beast was counting to $100,000
because he could do that.
I'm sure Mr. Beast had some
grand visions of giving away,
like $20 billion or something.
But you know,
you have to start where you can.
I think a lot of people as well,
they want to be on a higher level,
but you just need to work your way up,
especially if you're solo, right?
- Yeah, and I would argue
that in the case with YouTube,
it's not always like TV,
or it's not that,
just because you have TV quality,
it's going to make you
successful because I feel there's
still plenty of room,
especially on YouTube for,
"Less lower quality content" that is still
just as enjoyed as the
higher quality shit, right?
- Some of those popular
content on YouTube,
without a doubt,
is people just screen recording Minecraft.
- [Joey] Exactly.
- It speaks volumes about,
it says a lot about society
that you're just playing a game,
it's still going to be king.
And I think no matter how insane it gets,
like people at the end of the
day are going to want to watch
people fuck around and
playing video games.
Because there's just
something fun about it.
I don't know, I like it, I don't know.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And like, I know people always say like,
"Why do they always talk about
being a YouTuber and stuff?"
And it's like, fuck man, it's almost.
- I don't know, it's
almost like, it's our job.
- It's tough because like,
I also want to talk
about other things too,
but it's like,
man, like 99% of my day
is me doing content creation.
- Yeah.
- What's do guys talk about
when they go to the pub?
They talk about the
hard day at the office.
Their work.
This is exactly what we're doing.
I was like,
"You guys have aneurysm when
you try like to sort out stream
setups and stuff?"
I do.
- I do that.
- Yeah, I feel you bro.
- Right?
I do that.
This episode is sponsored by Bokksu.
- Guys, I've got a sudden craving.
For D snacks.
- Well, Joey, look, what's
right in front of you.
(Joey and Garnt gasping)
- Is that a Bokksu?
- What's a Bokksu?
- I'm glad you guy's asked
because I'm going to
tell you all about it,
right now.
Bokksu is a monthly snapbox
subscription service
that delivers original assortments
of premium Japanese
snacks and tea pairings.
Bokksu makes such a
perfect and memorable gift
for anyone in your life who appreciates
Japanese snacks and culture.
Especially, during a time where
people aren't able to travel
as easily as they would like to.
And actually, not only would
you be giving them a Bokksu,
but also you would also
be giving them the chance
to win free tickets to Japan.
- (speaks in Japanese)
- Did you just say for
free tickets to Japans.
- Free tickets to Japan
because Bokksu is having a giveaway
where they will be giving
away five lucky winners
to win a free set of tickets.
- Oh, my God.
- Anyone who is subscribed
before December 31st,
is automatically entered.
The link is in the description down below.
So, you can check out
the terms and conditions,
or other methods of entry.
- Use our code TrashTaste10,
in the link in description below,
to become eligible to win the giveaway
by subscribing to Bokksu.
And the code will get you 10%
off your subscription as well.
Don't miss out on this unique opportunity
available for anyone who
subscribes until December 31st.
- So what are you waiting for?
Check that link in the
description for a chance
to win a free trip to Japan.
It's free.
- Come to the Nihon.
- Come meet us.
- Wow, Trash Taste Studio tour.
- Back to the show.
Going back to what you're talking about,
how you're just bored
of the anime archetype,
or the anime character archetype.
What's like the last character
you would say from like,
any medium that you were just like,
"Yes."
I fuck with that.
- Not an archetype.
- I fuck with that.
- "Squid Games", right.
- For real?
- I was actually, yeah.
- Every character from "Squid Game".
- Well, every character is
like flawed from "Squid Game".
- Yeah, they're all pretty flawed.
- Yeah, but I would argue,
that's what made this
show so great, right?
Yes, because everyone sucked.
- Yeah.
- What I enjoyed about "Squid Game"
compared to like every other
let's say death game is,
a lot of other death games is that,
yeah, a lot of the death games
just run on complete archetypes.
Like this person's the asshole,
this person's the good guy.
- We did have the
asshole and the good guy.
- Yeah, we did, we did.
- But you would have bare minimum, right?
- Yeah, but the thing is,
at least I think why "Squid Game" worked,
is that they gave more time to develop
part of their characteristics
rather than them just being the archetype.
Right?
- True.
- There were entire
episodes of "Squid Game"
that didn't have any like death
game shit involved at all.
It was just, the characters,
getting to know each other,
knowing about the whole light backstory
of some of the characters.
One of my favorite episodes
of "Squid Game" is when,
I don't know if there's
going to be spoilers.
But it's like halfway
through when you know,
they all decide to quit "Squid Game"
and they all go back to the society.
- That's the second episode actually.
- It's literally second episode.
- It's like second episode, okay.
Spoilers for the second episode,
is when they all decide,
to massive vote to quit
and go back to society.
And then they realize how much
they go back to.
It really says a lot about society,
when they decide to go back
into the "Squid Game"s,
after how much they realize that
how much they life fucking sucks, right?
Like that episode is great because
you not only get to know
about all the characters,
and their backstories and
their relations to one at all,
but it also just like
puts into a situation of,
"Oh, this world must really suck to them
that they have to resort
to going back," right?
Like that was great.
- It wasn't a perfect show by any means.
- No, definitely not.
- And I find a lot of
things wrong with it,
and I understand why it's so popular.
Like it's very engaging.
It's got a pretty good premise,
and the characters like,
you hate some of them,
which is saying more than a
lot of shows can get, right?
A lot of characters.
I felt strongly that I disliked.
And a lot of shows like anime.
I barely feel fucking anything
about these fucking character.
- Yeah, that's what I would argue is that,
I think it really says
a lot about society.
- I can't fucking stop.
I swear, am not.
- I like heard you
processing that in your mind.
Because you're just like,
"I'm not going to say it.
I'm not going to say,"
and then you said, "It really,"
and then you were just like,
fuck, fuck, fuck.
- I swear I'm not saying it on purpose.
I say that a lot.
I just say that a lot.
- You're like, "It really,
abort, abort, abort,
says, abort, abort, abort, a lot,"
and I'm just like, "Oh, it's
too late, it's too late."
- About society.
- I say it so naturally
in my speech, fine.
This meme has ruined me.
What was I even saying? I don't even know.
- "Squid Game".
- I was saying like how
the characters are boring.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Yeah.
So, I was going to say that
I think a character that you end
up absolutely fucking hating
is a way better character
than a character you feel nothing towards.
- Right, 100%.
- Right.
And so many people think like,
"Oh, this character sucks
because I hate him."
I'm like, "Well, no, that
makes him a good character
because you feel something
towards that character."
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Right?
- It's like a ""Game of
Thrones"" and Joffrey.
I found it so interesting.
Have you seen like
interviews of the actor?
Of Joffrey?
- I felt so sorry for him.
- He's like such a cool guy.
He's like one of the nicest guy
I've ever seen.
- He quit acting.
- He quit acting, right? He quit acting,
- Did he actually?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, he quit
acting after "Game of Thrones".
And it just shows like,
I don't know if it was his first role,
but he was definitely like,
not an experienced actor, right?
But it just surprise, surprise,
a good actor,
makes a hateable character
even more hateable,
and I felt really sorry for
him hearing stories about
how kids.
Kids watch "Game of Thrones".
- Kids watch "Game of Thrones".
- Yeah, surprise.
But like people actually thought
that he was his character,
and people thought he was like an asshole.
And I'm just like, "What?"
- That blows my mind.
How people can like
actually look at an actor,
and think, "Bro, I bet Leonardo DiCaprio
says the N word all the time, bro.
And I saw him in "Django",
he said it, man, bro."
- That's like the same
people who are like, "Wow,
did you know that Joji
is just anime shitty of
a person as Filthy Frank.
It's like, it's the same thing.
It's like, "I can't believe
he's like that in real life."
It's definitely not a
character at this point.
- So, who just discovered "Filthy
Frank" for the first time?
- I love that shit.
- That's fucking hilarious.
- They try to fucking cancel him.
Just cause like, "Did you
know that five years ago
he was this Filthy Frank
character whose making fun of
like mentally, disabled people?"
Yes, yes, internet, we
did know, thank you.
- What kind of amusing
period to be on internet.
- How long ago was that?
Because it felt like yesterday.
- It was last year.
- It's about a year or two
ago and this is very funny.
- Yeah, times change,
and definitely something
like "Filthy Frank."
"Filthy Frank," transitioned to Joji.
- "Filthy Frank."
- I'm fucking I'm lisping like crazy, now.
- This says a lot about society.
- I've completely forgot my point, now.
- "Filthy Frank."
- Fuck, you've just like,
Derren Browned my mind.
- Am sorry.
- Fucking hacked my mind.
- This says a lot about society.
I'll stop, I'll stop.
- Now that I look back at it,
it really is an interesting
period that "Filthy Frank"
was living in
because for one, my God,
that shit would not fly.
And there's a good reason why he quit.
- It is strange how rapidly it changes.
- Yeah, but like, I don't know.
I also remember as well at the peak of,
Joji's career as Filthy Frank,
how there was so many
kids that thought that
that was just him.
- It was, that he was
so good at keeping up.
- Because he was so good at just acting
as the character and you know,
any normal person who'd
watched "Filthy Frank"
would know that, of course
that was an over-exaggeration.
That was a character.
- Well, I remember at a time,
Joji just didn't exist.
I remember once
didn't he like make a video
about him coming out as Joji.
And then he actually
deleted that or something.
- Yeah.
He made a vlog as George Miller.
Who's you know,
his real name as like himself,
and how he said that
he absolutely hated his fan base.
- Yeah.
- I guess the weird thing is that,
is tough to talk about is that,
I guess when you are hired
to play like Joffrey, right.
The actor didn't make this character.
The actor didn't make this story.
I just think that it's kind of difficult
to talk about with "Filthy Frank" is that,
okay, he chose to make this character,
this is entirely his thing.
So, it's like,
how does that play an effect into
how much of the character
do you excuse, right?
I don't really give a shit about it,
but it's interesting seeing
how other people talk about it,
and how much they think,
"Oh, this is appalling.
This is him doing it, "
et cetera, et cetera.
Because he does have control
over the character, right.
He makes the creative decisions.
So, I do wonder,
how much valid criticism
you can give him that
from that position, right?
- [Joey] Right.
- I think it's the same criticism
you'd give to any writer,
or anyone who writes a
script or a character.
Why not just cancel George RR Martin?
Why not cancel Quentin Tarantino
for some of the stuff he scripts,
and some of the characters he writes.
- I agree,
it's one of the things.
- Quentin Tarantino says
the N word all the time.
- Yeah, I know, it's weird.
Because it's like we're
in the YouTube era, right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I feel like the rules
have like kind of changed.
- Why though?
They shouldn't change.
- I know why, I agree with you.
I want to talk about it.
- I think it's because YouTube
just seem more personable than say
someone like Quentin Tarantino.
- Right, right.
- I'm not saying that's how I think,
but I think it's worth discussing.
- I think a lot of the people
who try to cancel other people
are, you know, a younger generation.
It's going to take a
learning experience of
when this younger generation
who are now in their teenage years.
When they grow up,
five, 10 years in the future,
and realize some of the
shit they're saying now
are things that can get them canceled
when they're an adult,
they realize, "Oh, okay,
maybe society just
changes as time goes on."
What's socially acceptable changes,
and you know, maybe we
should give some people
the benefit of the doubt.
Sometimes when things happen
10 years, five years ago.
- I guarantee you go back 10 years ago
like any Newgrounds comments, right?
And you see the amount of
people throwing the R word,
and the F word and the N
word around in comments.
Like it means nothing
because back then on the internet,
it was just a general understanding that
none of that meant anything
because it was the internet.
Now, you look at it now and,
if you wrote any kind of
comment or tweet like that,
it's insta canceled.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Two points, two points, two points.
First of all,
why do you think that some
people would then try and cancel
someone like "Filthy Frank", right?
Who's a YouTuber and playing a character.
Why do you think they were
trying to cancel it him?
But not say someone else
who's just like playing a character.
- I think it's because now
the younger generation
who don't know about
"Filthy Frank", right.
They only know George as Joji,
who was this innocent guy
who just makes music, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And you know, it's to them,
"Filthy Frank" is like
his dark past, you know,
it's something.
It really is, it is.
It's his dark past.
It's like, " Wow,
I can't believe he
changed identities online
to try and hide the fact
that he did some dark shit in the past."
- That has a fucking villain
backstory, you know that.
- Yeah, it does, yeah.
- It's like his evil upbringing, right?
It's like that's how some
people perceived it though,
which just made it so funny
because I think to a lot of
these people who try to cancel
Georgie as "Filthy Frank"
thought that he changed his name
to hide the "Filthy Frank" era.
Everyone who grew up with "Filthy Frank"
knows that, "No, that's not the case."
He just didn't want to keep
making content like that.
It didn't make him any money
because of the changing
landscape of YouTube.
And he just wanted to focus on music.
- I'll save my other question for later.
But next question then
following up on that.
- Question to you guys.
- Question to you guys, right.
Okay, so, if we had a "Filthy Frank" now,
that came out now,
do you think it would be any different?
- Yeah.
- Totally.
- Do you think it would never be a thing?
- No.
Dude.
I'm sure you've seen enough
"Filthy Frank" videos
to know that 90% of the shit
he made would not fly today.
- Right, but like, why is it that
we look back at that fondly,
and we look back at these
videos and then we have.
- It's because we lived through them.
- True, true, true.
- Yeah, right.
And we know that it wasn't serious.
We knew that it was a caricature.
It wasn't over-exaggeration.
- I always wonder as well,
I'm like, okay,
you have to play a character, right?
And you get to do this stuff.
I wonder though like,
how much are you allowed to do?
As said character?
Where does it stop?
Where you're like,
"Okay, this is too much."
- Oh, it all depends on the time.
And what's acceptable at the time.
- I remember, back when
our parents growing up,
it was cool to look up to rock
stars who trashed hotel rooms
did fucking drugs until,
they were more cocaine
than bloods, you know?
That was what was cool at the time.
It was what was acceptable at the time.
- I just imagined
it's like a TikToK of someone being like,
"I worked at the hotel that
Who stayed at and it was
like really fucked up.
They've trashed the room
and everything. And like,
you shouldn't support them."
Because I can just envision it.
- The Who is canceled
for being rock stars.
- That's the thing though.
I understand time has changed.
- Honestly, like we joke about that,
but it might honestly be the case.
- That's what's would happen nowadays.
- Because you don't hear about
like rock bands anymore
doing shit like that, right?
I feel they're scared now
that the possibility of that happening.
- The rock star of then is dead.
- The repercussions just like,
at the time they could get away with it
without repercussions.
And that was just what was
like accepted at the time,
I'm not saying it's right.
- It was rock and roll.
- Yeah, it was rock and roll.
- Yeah, yeah, I mean, obviously,
- I mean, I don't know how some
of these fucking rock stars
are still alive honestly,
hearing some of the fucking thing stories.
- Oh yeah.
Like Keith Richards.
He should have died like 50 years ago
from the amount of cocaine he did.
He's still playing with
the Rolling Stones.
It's like actually amazing.
Like he's actually like,
he's Dio.
He's 100% Dio.
- I don't know.
I love talking about all that stuff.
And like considering it
because it's just so difficult to like,
get anyone to like give you
a good definitive answer
of where they think things lie.
It's so up to interpretation.
- Yeah, it is up to
interpretation and I think
it really just depend on the person.
- I think there's probably
a lot of people watching this podcast
who have probably watched "Filthy Frank"
and think the shit like cringe
or like too much, right?
And there's some videos
where I look back, I'm like,
"Okay."
- There was some videos where I'm like,
"Okay, that's a little too far."
- Right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I think part of it is
just acknowledging that,
society changes.
Especially things that are comedic,
a lot of comedy pushes the
edges, pushes the edge.
A lot of the times in what is acceptable
in that time period,
and just because like, there is shit
I found funny 10 years ago
that is very cringe or like very like,
"Sh, uh, I don't know
about that on, chief."
- Bottles to Newgrounds Animation.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
But like, I acknowledge
that part of that is just
because the times were different,
and it's not that I was a bad person,
it's not that we were bad kids
or the type of people
there were, inherently bad.
It was just,
what is acceptable changes
as time goes on as different issues,
different social issues get
brought up to the limelight,
and you're just like,
"Okay, well now that's say the
social issue is brought up.
I do no longer find this one thing funny."
And then, that's part
of how society evolves.
- Yeah, I mean, you know,
I still fondly remember
when I was growing up with Newgrounds,
and just seeing so many
Newgrounds animations,
which at the time
I thought was like the
funniest on the planet.
Like the first time I watched
"Ultimate Showdown of Ultimate Destiny",
I thought that was the funniest
I've ever seen in my life.
And I watch it now and
I'm like, "That's cute."
It's like, I can't laugh at it.
I can reminisce about it.
But I try to like throw my head back,
and loft around it anymore
because it's just something,
as you said,
it's just completely changed
with not just how I perceive
comedy, but just how society.
- Can we stop saying society.
- I can't, it's in my mind now.
- It's such a power.
But like, you know,
how the world perceives comedy all like,
the barrier for comedy, right?
- Another thing that
I wanted to talk about
I wanted your opinion on
is that you were mentioning about,
how you could say anything you
wanted to say in the comments
and the people don't give a shit.
In the UK,
did you see that they were
trying to get a law past,
to like,
have it so that you
need your like public ID
to sign up to websites.
- [Joey] Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Then you could be like
criminally charged if you
bully people online.
They were trying to get that in the UK.
- Yeah.
- Really.
- There was a similar
law like that in Japan
actually years ago.
- Really.
- With 2chan.
When 2chan was a thing.
Well, I mean, 2chan
started to become a thing,
and it started to get really serious
is that there were many
politicians that were like,
"If you want to use 2chan
or any kind of message board
in Japan, you need to put
like your real identity,
and get like properly ID and
scans to avoid cyber bullying.
- Turn off all site
which haven't an ID card.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Right, right.
And the, I remember the
founder of 2chan, Hiroyuki,
he went on TV campaigning against it
because he was like,
"That's just censoring."
Like that goes completely against
the whole point of sites,
like 2chan and just internet
and stuff like that.
I mean, he was ruthless about it.
He basically said, "If he can't
handle it, then fuck off."
In some aspects,
yes, I agree with, but in
other aspects I do see like,
especially nowadays with kids who-
- Oh, shit can get hard.
- ...have no show whatsoever, right?
They just think they can go ham
on everything without thinking
of any repercussions, right.
- Yeah, it's weird, man.
Obviously, I can sympathize with people
who have had some really awful experiences
with public shaming and stuff like that.
I imagine it's not easy to deal with.
- [Joey] No.
- Yeah.
- But on the other hand,
it's like, all right, I get it.
But come on, anonymity
is an amazing thing.
And it empowers a lot of people.
I feel like when you try
and take away anonymity
from people,
it disproportionately
affects people who are
in worse positions.
So,
it's weird.
And also I thought, okay,
so let's say I have to make
ID to join Twitter in the UK,
bra, am just boot up that VPN,
and to go to America,
I'm not signing up with my ID.
Are you kidding me?
Even as a public figure,
I do not want to give
my ID to like Twitter.
- Yeah.
- I do not want to do that.
- But that's the thing where I was like,
anonymity is such how-
- Have you not?
- No.
- Do you not need to
give it for verification?
- Oh, wait, you do.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, you do.
I guess I did.
- Checkmate.
- I don't want to.
I don't want to, but I have to.
- Twitter's like checkmate.
- Checkmate we have your shit.
- Fuck, I just realized it.
- We know who you are.
- Connor, "I would never
give up my ID for Twitter.
I would rather go to war," jokes.
- But that tick mark though.
- But the verification.
- That tick mark dome, enticing.
- I can't wait for this
fucking Garnt enthusiasm thing.
- Poorly aged things.
- Literally, took like five seconds.
As just like a general user.
- I get what you mean
though, I get what you mean.
- It's stupid.
- No, but that's the thing
is like I was saying, like,
I think that's, what's so powerful
about anonymity is that I think
true anonymity is so difficult to achieve
outside of the internet.
- Yeah, that's impossible.
- That that's what makes it
so powerful on the internet
because it's really the
only place on the planet
where you can really just
be completely anonymous.
And do and say shit.
- I mean,
I hate the fact that some
people are just really appalling
to me online sometimes
for no particular reason,
but I'm not going to
sit there and be like,
"Yo, people that means
nobody gets to enjoy
the freedoms of the internet."
And there's a lot of countries
where that's like life or death.
Anonymity is very important.
Like I would never, ever
want to take that away.
And for a blue check marks, okay.
- I can just imagine someone's
like talking shit to me,
right?
Like quote retweeting
saying something mean.
And I be like, "What's your identity?
Show me how old you are.
Where do you live?"
Let me contact the internet police.
- Oh, wait, that's a thing now.
- The cyber police.
- So, what are you going do?
Go to prison because you
fucking racialed someone.
- Calling on my cyber lawyer.
- How are you going to
define bullying like that?
This is the reason why
bullying laws have never,
ever worked.
How the fucking do you define bullying?
Like one men's insult is
another men's like Peppy laugh.
Like, I don't know, man.
What some people may
find funny and jovial,
other people might find
like deeply offensive.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But half the time,
if you're super offended
by something like that,
it's probably on.
- Yeah, no,
I get like the whole thing of like,
cyber thing is like a real thing.
It's not just a simple matter of,
"Oh, just, just close
your eyes or," you know,
"Just get off the internet."
- "Just don't look, right."
- Yeah, "Just don't look at it," right.
It's obviously not that simple.
But at the same time it's like, yeah.
People's thresholds of
what they're offended by
is very different.
- I don't think there
is a perfect solution
because yes, I do think people would need
to like chill out online.
And I don't agree that
the right solution to that
is by monitoring everyone,
and kind of having to
make it like a default thing
where you have to give up your ID,
any your anonymity and stuff like that.
- They already have that shit anyway.
Why do they need it?
They already Know that,
like the government doesn't fucking
already know everything about this.
- Yeah, right.
- Yeah.
- It's not like they're
tracking you everyday.
- They know what Hentai am watching.
They don't need to put
cookies on my browser.
I'll straight up tell them
bro, "Leave me alone."
- I know, yeah.
So, I guess,
my philosophy behind it
is just like to keep
your manners in check.
If you do see someone
acting like a dick head,
it's kind of a social thing now.
- You just say, "Oi,
stop being a dick head.
- Stop being anime dick head, dick head.
- Yeah.
It's not hard.
- I need to piss quickly.
- Oh, my god,
this man needs to piss
every two damn seconds.
- He has downed like half of the bottle.
- One thing that me off
about this debate, right,
is that they always just
piggyback off of like,
really tragic events
to push their agenda of
we can't have anonymity
with people dying out here
from an anonymity and it's like,
you're just using like
really tragic events to push your agenda.
- Wait, how are people
dying from anonymity?
- Like cyber bullying people,
like the very famous one
with the terrace house girl.
- Oh, yes, yes, yes, yes.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I forget the name.
I remember that that whole
started a debate as well.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- And then I know that
with the English football players,
people have been like
super racist towards them.
It's very fucked up.
And then that's when the
debate really started going.
And it's like, yeah, this is horrible.
But like the bigger picture is like
they're trying to like take away.
I sound like American.
- Freedom, freedom.
- Freedom.
- Your already resigned so much.
Why you just like giving it to them?
Like, "Hey, take it, please, please."
- And it's like people are still racist.
Whether there are anonymous or not, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- I feel like we're not getting
to the root of the problem.
- Go to the Facebook groups.
They literally got that
whole family tree on there.
And they're saying the worst shit,
they ain't going to change anything.
- It was like, "Oh cool.
My uncle just joined the
KKK fan club on Facebook."
It's like, great.
It's not anonymous.
It's still racist.
That's the problem, right?
As you said,
it's like the using the
anonymous excuse to cover up
the actual root of the problem, right.
It's like the root of the
problem is not this anonymous
person saying racist shit.
It's the problem that,
that person is a racist.
- Sometimes I wish one
of those was just like
fucking weird as fuck.
So, you would just be like,
"Yeah, dude, I'm like,
anti-vax, 5G hater."
It's just so that we'd have
like more interesting debates.
- More interesting.
- Just because I'm like,
"Why are you going to be sensible?
What the fuck?
Like stop agreeing with me for a change."
- God forbid we have common sense.
- God fucking damn it.
Like, I don't want it to be
in like conspiracy theory.
- Why are you not like
part of the KKK fan club?
- Let's just invite Alex
Jones to "Trash Taste".
Just balance it out.
- A question for you.
- We wouldn't be able to
contain Alex Jones, man.
Who are we kidding?
Why are you going to be so
damn sensible all the time?
Fuck you guys.
- Oh, God.
- Oh, my God.
- I guess this is like
piggyback on like the discussion
we had last week about,
about hearing what the other
sides has to say, right.
And I can't remember exactly what I said
to like end of the podcast.
Because that's how it is
on "Trash Taste" podcast.
I do remember thinking one
thing I actually like doing,
is actually, I like going to-
- Yeah, we follow people
from the other side.
- Yeah, we like following
people from the other side
just to see
what they're thinking or
what their argument is.
So, one thing I actually liked doing,
is I like to see what some of like,
say the craziest people
are thinking, right?
Not because I want to believe them,
just because I'm like,
so curious about how they
got to that point, right.
So, one thing I like doing
is just listening to like
flat-earthers
defense what they believe.
Defend flat-earther, right?
- Have you seen how weird the flat earth,
like online presence is though.
Like how much like
anti-Semitism there as well.
Like weirdly, yeah.
It's really bizarre.
- I did see a video of a guy.
I think it was a vice documentary of a guy
going to like a flat earth convention.
- Maybe it was all gas, no brakes.
- No, it wasn't all gas, no brakes.
It was like a proper like documentary
of a guy going to flat earth convention.
I couldn't even get mad
at the stuff that we're talking about.
Because like anyone sensible can tell you
that what they're saying
is just dudu kaka.
But like at the same time I
was so fascinated being like,
I genuinely wonder how
you got to this point.
Like not even to like hate.
Like psychologically,
I'm just curious.
- Yeah, exactly.
- What you had to input,
and what you had to be surrounded by,
in order for you to truly
believe that the earth is flat.
- Yeah.
And like looking into it and
seeing like so many different,
like fucking flat-earthers
as in different videos
about flat-earthers, I'm just like,
"Oh, a lot of this just comes down to like
a core distrust of the government,
and a system."
Like a systematic distrust.
It's so much of a distrust that,
they would rather believe
that the earth is flat,
than believe what scientists say
and what an organization like NASA says.
It's fascinating.
And it's also hilarious that, to them,
NASA is basically just like
the fucking Illuminati.
- The problem is that
we've actually had real
conspiracies happen.
So, people just have like
this weird confidence
that like it's happened before.
We've proven that these
some conspiracy theories
have happened.
It has happened in the past.
And so they get like
weirdly confident about it.
I think in a sense from
some stuff like that.
I don't know.
I don't have this mindset.
Stuff like that is so far from
where I have a view of things.
I can't even begin to, like.
- I can't even begin to like dive in that.
- No, I can't.
- No.
- I don't even understand like how.
And I think this is the problem is that
like a lot of people
just cannot even remotely
see where they're coming from.
Like with politics sometimes,
you can kind of understand, right.
You disagree,
but you can somewhat
understand very readily online,
but with stuff like this ,
it's so in like to us,
it's so insane, right?
I don't even know how to begin to be like,
"Yeah, you have a point."
I don't even know how to entertainment it.
I don't know, I don't know.
- I know, to me.
It's just like, it's
not about entertaining.
I'm just genuinely curious.
I'm just like genuinely.
I'm like, not even trying
to change your mind.
I'm just like genuinely curious.
How the fuck did you get to this point.
- Is it something that
starts from like a young age?
I don't know.
- I don't know, yeah.
- For me,
it's not even the point of
like me trying to figure out
if I can even say, "Yeah,
you've got a point."
For me, all the time, it's just "Go on."
I'm listening,
but I'm not going to like
take in anything you say.
I am just listening.
- It's weird because my
whole life growing up, right?
I've never met anyone
who's been into like really bizarre
stuff like that well, not openly.
So, it's kind of like weird for me.
I've expressed my whole life.
Like I understand now as an adult,
I can kind of have my own circles,
but I wonder why I was like
growing up and like university,
and stuff like that,
how I've never really met anyone
who's been very hardcore into
this, at least in the UK.
I don't know about elsewhere.
- I think it's maybe because
they kind of come dime a dozen, right?
I think media just makes it so out
that there was this like
massive large community that
flat-earthers or whatever.
- I think it's getting bigger.
- It is getting bigger.
- I still don't think
it's to the point where
it's become noticeably bigger, you know?
Like I still think at the end of the day,
it is still very, very tiny population
that actually is involved in this.
- It's hard to say, right?
It's hard to say.
- At least to the point where,
they're willing to go to
a convention about it.
- It definitely feels
like it's getting bigger.
Before I remember hearing
about flat-earthers,
and I would just laugh,
like that was just like an
urban legend or something.
And then you realize that people
like this actually exists.
They're getting larger
because they have a platform
to be able to get larger on,
which is, you know, the internet.
- I mean, I guess the fact that
an entire convention exists about this.
- Exactly, right.
- The thing that I hate about it as well,
is I hate talking about it,
because the more you talk about it,
the more you like give them a
strange sense of confidence.
Because we're so sure.
Because we're so sure that we
know that the earth is round.
We know that.
- Yeah.
- And it's weird.
I feel like the fact that we
almost keep talking about it,
and being like,
"Yeah, we know, we know it
is you're dumb, you're dumb."
They think,
"Oh, it's just adding to the conspiracy,"
because you know,
it's what I've been told to.
That everyone's going
to tell me I'm stupid,
and everyone's against me.
And so it's this weird thing
where I'm like, all right,
we just never gave them,
any kind of credence before
we never paid any attention to them,
hundreds of years ago when they said,
oh, hundreds years, I think it was fine.
But you know, like not 1930s,
what I don't know, they
didn't give fucking shit.
They were like,
"Whatever, you're crazy.
You have a nice day."
They wouldn't talk about it, right.
But now, because it's so well discussed,
and it's our world spoken about,
I feel like it almost lends itself more
confidence on more avenues,
to people who are susceptible
to stuff like that,
to get into it.
- Yeah.
I feel the more we talk about it,
the more it just gives
that group of people power.
Like, "Oh, you finally recognized us.
Yes, we do exist."
- That's why I always
come from a place of,
I want to understand the other side
because I feel like it's-
- Do you, do you understand?
- I do.
I do kind of understand where they-
- Why do you think it comes from?
Why do you think it comes from?
How does the person get to like believing
in something like that?
- Well, a lot of it, like I said,
is such a distrust of the system.
- Where do you think it comes from?
- Yeah, where does the distrust
of the system come from?
- I mean, there's a lot of things
that it could come from.
A big thing is religion as well.
A lot of flat-earthers you see,
are very, very religious people,
not to say that religion
is the core cause of this.
I have to fucking preface that
- Religion, bad.
- I have to preface that as someone
who is religious myself.
- Right, right.
But it's people who are,
who distrust, like
distrust the government,
distrust organizations so much that's
conspiracy theories to them
seem more palatable
than what everyone else
is telling them,
they've grown up in an environment
where it's like,
don't trust what everyone
else is telling you.
And because everyone around them
is telling them that they're wrong.
That only, like you said,
strengthens their views
and looks for more reasons
for them to like believe in the system.
Believe what they've come to believe.
- I'm sympathetic in some ways.
I feel like even though,
yeah, you're right.
Like, they don't trust in the systems,
almost because I think in a lot of ways
the systems have failed them,
like systems that,
we take for granted
because we had good upbringings,
we're very lucky
that we had very ordinary
"Lives,"
had a good education, I suppose.
And I feel like,
if you're not unfortunate
enough to just kind of
not have access to a lot of things,
and you're told that certain organizations
or things should protect you,
or just to learn from these things,
and you don't, and they let you down.
I can understand why you'd
almost not trust these systems.
They're supposed to be
put in place to help you.
- Yeah.
- So yeah.
It's tough, it's tough.
- Yeah, which is why
I like doing a show like this,
because especially on the internet,
with how online discourse is.
Like I said, last week,
people would know what they stand against,
but very few people know
what they stand for.
And that's just because
it's so much easier
to like prove someone else
wrong than prove yourself right.
All right.
It's come to a point
where I want to understand
the other side,
because one thing that's missing from
a lot of online discourse
and online discussions
is people are trying to
fucking understand each other.
Everyone's just trying
to prove each other wrong
rather than having a healthy debate.
I think having an understanding
of the other side,
is the first step to
having a healthy debate.
And so if I can understand flat-earthers,
then who the fucking on the
internet can't I understand,
and that's why I do this shit.
- If open conversations when
normalized on the internet,
we'd all be driving flying
cars, you know, like yeah,
exactly side.
But unfortunately we
are still on the ground.
- Yeah.
- It says a lot of our society.
- We can't even have an open conversation
about flat-earthers or not.
- It's like, okay,
people,
very dump.
But also extremely susceptible, right?
- [Joey] Yes.
- Okay.
Any like war ever, right.
You have to convince your people
that you want to fight something.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- How do you do that?
How do you convince a whole
population of people that.
- I don't know, ask Hitler.
- Right?
But that's the thing, right?
And I believe this was
like really well-documented
after world war two.
- Well, what if there's a very small,
but possible chance that
you have weapons of mass destruction?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I'm joking out.
- Or, they've got a bit of oil.
They've got a bit of oil.
Stock prices go boom.
- You like cars?
Do you like driving?
- I'll find the video link,
Garnt asked me.
I watched this video
and it was by this guy,
and it was basically talking about
how we'll go to after world war two,
a few Jewish people who had fled,
and a few scientists who lived in America.
They wanted to study how
people could go along
with like really bad atrocities
in like world war II, right?
What made your everyday
guy, like a normal dude,
just kind of like sign up and be like,
"Okay, we'll we'll do this."
- Oh yeah.
- Like the whole the Nazi party.
- Yeah, how they just kind of,
and some of the really horrible stuff,
how you could convince people
that this was the right thing to do.
And it was basically explaining how, like,
there was like certain
traits that one might have,
which would make you more
susceptible to end up doing
something like that.
Some personality traits.
It was really interesting
because it's stuff that like,
you wouldn't think correlates to you.
Like you think, "Oh, I'm
really strong-willed."
But maybe you like strong leaders,
strong leaders to ask
you to do bad things.
"Oh, maybe he's justified it
in a way that makes sense,"
right.
I think we all like to
think that we are like this,
oh, what's the word?
- Impenetrable.
- Impenetrable, fortress of mind,
that nobody can affect our opinion
or woo us to do something
that we would never do.
I think in reality,
we're a lot more fickle.
- It happens all the time.
- I mean, there is literally
a psychological experiment
that's a details that.
I can't remember the exact
name of the experiments.
- It's on Josh's Podcast.
I remember this thing.
I can't exactly remember it.
I roughly went a long.
- I know, Ashley, can you
search up the experiment?
It's fuck.
- [Ashley] That's the prisoner one, yeah?
- No, that one was bullshit.
- It's not the prison,
that's the Stanford one.
- Can you explain it?
- Is it the electricity one?
- Yeah, it's the electricity one.
So, it's the one where.
- Authority.
Basically they'll tell that there's happy.
- Is it Milgram Experiment.
- [Ashley] I don't know
what experiment you're talking about.
- They'll turn up the electricity
because somebody tells them to do it.
Because they say that it's like a good,
but then they have like
a fake person screaming
while they're turning up the electricity,
and someone keeps telling
them to keep doing it,
and they keep doing it.
Because a doctor or an authority figure
is telling them to keep doing it.
- So it's basically like
fake "Squid Game", right?
So you're put into a room.
- Why did you have to bring,
this is part of like the deepest
debate we were ever having.
And Garnt is like, "It's kind
of like a society we live in,
like "Squid Game".
- You could've just said liar game,
there's better examples.
- Okay, Ashley.
- [Ashley] Ugh, I think it's
called the Milgram Experiment.
- Milgram's Experiment, that's it?
I said, Milner, it's Milgram.
And basically the whole thing is framed
as a memory exercise, right?
So, you, the person
who's the being
experimented on, basically.
You're told that you're going to take part
in a memory exercise,
and you're going to sit in a
room with a person next to you.
And one of you is going
to be the person learning.
to be the tester, right?
And so what you're told is that
if you are given an electric shock,
if you get an answer
wrong, then in theory,
then you should be a better learner
because your doing like shock therapy.
That's what you're told.
Obviously, that's complete bullshit
because this experiment's got nothing
to do with a memory, right.
So, one of you by chance,
is the learner.
One of you is the teacher,
or the experimenter or the teacher.
But in reality,
you're going to be given
the teacher, right.
Because you're the only
person who's actually being
experimented on, right.
And so the other person who is the learner
goes in another room,
and you have to give them
a memory quiz, right.
And the problem is they're
going to get it wrong.
And that's part of the design
of the experiments, right.
And you're shown,
you're given a taste of
what the electric shock
that they're going to be
feeling feels like, right.
And this like on the lowest level, right.
And so as this experiment goes on,
originally, they get the questions, right.
And then they get one answer wrong.
And so you have to administer
them an electric shock,
and they feel like pain, right.
And you hear them feel pain.
You don't see it, but you
hear them in another room,
even though it's just a prerecording.
And then as they get more questions wrong,
the scientist tells you
to up the voltage and
administer the shock, right.
And they keep getting it wrong, right.
And so the scientists keeps
telling you to up the voltage,
and keep administering this
electric shock until to a point
where like, they are fucking
screaming out in agony,
or you can hear them on the
speaker screaming out in agony.
And then it gets to a point
when it's just silence, right.
And it's just silence,
and then the scientists keeps telling you,
"Just up the voltage. Up the voltage.
Keep going, keep going."
And like the amounts of people who,
even though they were totally
uncomfortable with the fact
that they could hear someone
screaming from the fact that
they were administering
this electric shock,
and it still went silent,
they went all the way up to the end.
And they still administered
like the most high voltage in
their mind electric shock to this person.
- What a big brain experiment?
- Because we trust authority figures.
- And like, it just proved that
a lot of people,
the majority of people
will be willing to listen
to a person who they view
as an authority figure to
tell them to do something.
Even if it's like a bad thing.
- Even if it goes against
what they believe, yeah.
- Even if it's a horrible act.
It's a very interesting
psychological experiment.
- Scam.
- It could be turned into a "Squid Game".
That's what I said,
this kind of sounds like
a "Squid Game", right?
- It's literally has nothing to do with.
- It kind of sounds like a "Squid Game".
- The writers for season two
are like, "Write that down."
- This literally has nothing
to do with "Squid Game".
- "Squid Game" season
two Milgram's experiment.
- This literally has nothing
to do with "Squid Game".
- I want to see Milgram's experiment,
and "Squid Game" season two.
- The shock game.
But it's like actually a
shock, they actually die.
See, that's just goes to show how,
there's so many people who
say like I'm not gullible.
But we all are to a certain degree.
I feel, we constantly get told
to do things that originally
go against what we believe in,
or very easily persuaded by just someone,
even if they don't have that
much of an authoritative,
vibe about them to just be
like, "Oh, well, I mean,
this person who in my mind is
more authoritative about this
particular subject than I am,
is saying something."
- That's the point, yeah,
you just trust them.
- Like the whole fact that,
we have a literal audience
of people who will probably
change their mind about
something we say on the show
or something we say on our own channels.
- Animes maybe.
- If I say so-and-so anime sucks.
So, there's probably a number
of people who are like,
"Yeah, you're probably right."
Even though I have zero authority
over that person, right.
It's just scary.
And I know that happens
because it's the opposite
has happened to me as well.
- It's happens to all of us.
- Yeah, it happens to all of us.
- It's the reason why we have conflict.
People are good at persuading people.
- I feel like we're just breaking
down the most fundamental
problem about humanity.
It's like, "You are not me."
- We've got like three deep conversations
on three episodes in a row now.
This is deep taste now.
This is like deep talk.
- Deep taste.
- Why you going to word it like that?
- We went from shitty to this.
- Deep taste, bro.
- Is deep in fancy font?
- Yeah.
- [Connor And Garnt] Deep taste.
- No wonder that sounds so gross.
- It's not gross.
It's only gross if you make it gross.
- Have you played Metal Gear Solid 1?
- No.
- What?
- Have you played Metal Gear Solid 1?
- Yeah.
- I never like caught on to this as a kid.
But remember when Snake gets a call
from like a random person,
at the time,
you don't know who it is,
it's just static on screen.
He tells Snake to call him,
"Just call me Deep Throat."
And I'm just like, how's
did I never registered that
as a kid.
- What was the content?
Why did he tell him the
call him Deep Throat?
- Because he has a deep voice,
and that's the reason.
As a kid playing I'm like,
that's a cool name, Deep Throat.
- It's like the dominatrix
thing all over again.
It's just going to be another thing.
- Hideo Kojima, do you
know what you're doing?
Or are you just like is your
mind is built differently?
- He definitely plan that out for sure.
Remember when he went
around to everyone to calm
and he was like,
"Check this out."
- Maybe it was a mistranslation.
- I came up with the best idea.
- Maybe it was a mistranslation who knows?
- I mean, if anything,
it's probably not even a mistranslation.
It's probably a direct translation
because we don't call it that in Japanese.
So, it was probably like
to a Japanese audience.
So it was like, Deep Throat,
it was like, "Wow."
- "Wow, that sounds cool."
- That's fucking cool.
Hell yeah, dude.
- Deep Throat.
(Joey speaks in Japanese)
- You sound like Japanese
Harry Potter, bro.
- That is my favorite thing though.
When they take like just
ridiculous English words,
and just like directly say it in Japanese.
The Japanese think it's the
coolest sounding thing ever,
even though it sounds
goofy as fuck in Japanese.
- It's always also just Hideo Kojima,
- That man is on one.
- Yeah. He's on one.
Has any of you played a
"Death Stranding" yet?
- No.
- I really want to,
and then I also really don't want to,
you know what I mean?
It's one of those games where,
I see so many clips out of context.
I want to play this just
to see this in context.
- This is like the first
trend type of game.
- I just couldn't fucking believe
that the final cuts
scene is two hours long.
- Yeah, you have to understand, right?
You guys know, I don't like cut scenes.
I actually like, I cannot play that game.
- I can just imagine you getting
to that final cut scene,
and the moment you press the skip button,
you miss about 5% of the game.
- Can you even skip?
- I can just imagine
you starting the game,
and you're just like,
where's the gameplay start.
You just walk in.
Where's the gameplay?
- That would be the angriest livestream
I'd have probably ever had to.
- I would love to watch
your play "Death Stranding".
I was going to say deep straining.
- Deep.
- Deep straining.
- I don't know.
- It didn't look very good. I don't think.
- Dunkey enjoyed it, the
third time he played it.
- Third time.
- Yeah.
- Yeah,
and his like the most
monkey brain game after.
- No his not.
- He has more patience than me.
- Well, I mean,
I think it says a lot that
Dunkey enjoyed a game like that.
- It says a lot.
- Like he hates.
- It says a lot about Dunkey.
- It says a lot about Dunkey,
when he enjoys the "Death Stranding"
but he can't stand a single JRPG.
- I understand though.
JRPG are mind numbing.
- I don't want to get into that topic.
- We've already spoken about
that like a million times.
- I don't want to.
JRPG is bad.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, he ruined it.
- Yeah, that's all.
I was saying like, I love like,
the whole thing about like Japanese,
just like directly translating
English names into Japanese,
and then the Japanese thinking it's cool.
Like Harry Potter characters
are a perfect example of that.
- Okay.
- Like Dumbledore, right?
Really cool English name.
Dumbledore is not a cool man.
- I kind of fuck with it.
- I don't know.
Every time I hear a Harry Potter character
said in a Japanese
pronunciation, I'm just like,
"How did that sound 10 times
goofier than the English name?"
- I can't think of Dumbledore now
without thinking about the meme of like,
- I can't either.
Of like the Dumbledore said calmly meme.
- Did you write your name
on the Goblet of Fire?
- That meme has physically
ruined those movies to me.
I literally,
I cannot watch the "Goblet of Fire"
because all I will be doing
is waiting for that scene.
- And then the moment it
gets to that scene you just
turn it off.
It's like, am satisfied.
- I'm done, I'm done, I'm done.
- I'll be like giggling away.
And someone be like,
"What's wrong, Connor?"
I'm like, "Nothing, you
wouldn't understand this."
- He said it so calmly.
In case you didn't know.
There's this meme where like in the book
it's like Stephen Fry's
narrating it going,
"And Dumbledore said calmly,"
and then it cuts to the movie.
Like someone edit it and then
it's just Dumbledore again,
"Did you write your name
on the Goblet of Fire?"
It was just like, so fucking dumb.
- [Stephen Fry] Did you put your name
into the goblet of fire, Harry?
- [Dumbledore] Harry,
did you write your name
into the Goblet of Fire?
Please go and watch it.
- It's so good.
- It's kind of like the equivalent,
of a "Trash Taste" viewer saying,
"And then Garnt said, he prefers
bone on chicken, calmly."
- Calmly.
- Cut to the "Trash Taste" clip.
I was having a discussion yesterday.
We've spoken a lot about
good Japanese food.
Can we speak about Japanese food that
fucking straight up sucks?
- Be my guest.
- First of all.
- What do you think sucks?
- You go to the user card, right?
You boys are ordering, you
all like ordering, right?
You're getting Gyoza.
Gyoza is good.
You're getting maybe some Yakiniku, right.
Meat on a stick, right?
Great.
- Yakitori, you mean?
- Yakitori, sorry.
- Yeah.
I mean, you can get some Yakiniku,
maybe I don't know.
- And an Isekai, some fancy ass Isekai.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Maybe you get some fried
chicken with the bones.
Maybe someone orders
something and you're like,
"Oh, this is fried chicken, right?"
And you eat it.
You're like, "Why is it tastes like bone?"
- Oh, it's Tendons.
- It's like
- [All] Cartilage.
- For some reason they just
like deep fried cartilage.
And it's like the worst eating experience.
- I love that shit, dude.
- It's like, imagine greasy bones.
It's literally greasy bones
is what it feels like.
- I love that shit.
It's like your crunching a
small animals, bones with oil.
Like it's awful.
- You got insert dominance.
- I agree with you, Connor.
It's fucking awful.
- Put it there, Garnt.
Gentleman's agreement.
- That's a historical moment right there,
ladies and gentlemen.
They agree on something.
- It's so bad.
Like, I don't know how you like it.
- I used to hate it.
If that's any consideration.
- What happened to you?
- This is the man who would eat anything.
This is the man who will eat anything.
- I understand you'll eat anything.
But there has to be some
dishes where you got like,
"I'll eat it. But life
is kind of whack." Right?
- Olives.
- What?
- [Connor And Garnt] - What?
- Joey's like fermented fish shit,
chopped with fermented soybeans,
love it can't get enough.
But Joe he's like, "Olives."
- I do not like olives.
- Why?
- Bro, Italians a crying, right now.
- Yeah, I mean like I like olive oil.
I like olive on pizza.
- Why, what part is it?
Is it the seed?
- It's just too strong of a flavor.
- You like olive oil?
- Oh, yeah.
I don't like fucking
down a pint of olive oil
on my spare time.
- Are you Italian?
No,
shocker.
I am wearing a lot of
references to an Italian guy,
but, no, am not Italian.
- It just came out of nowhere.
- So Joey, he doesn't olives.
- I'll eat any kind of fermented shit,
but I draw the line on olives.
One green boy.
- Joey, the man who tried,
who tried like bird fetus.
And I'm like, "I kind of fuck with it."
Olive, "No, get that shit out of here."
- When I say I don't like olives,
- Green or black, both?
- Green, mostly I don't.
Yeah. Black olives I like actually.
- Green are stronger, normally.
- Green is a little stronger.
And it's like, and when I
say I don't like olives,
it's not that if I get
a plate of green olives,
I'm not going to eat it at all.
- Have you seen that clip?
Sorry to interrupt but,
I just have this image
of Joey being that person
where it's shows a clip of
like a talk show or something.
And the host goes, "Bring
out the olives," and like,
they bring out a jar of olives,
this woman just starts fucking losing it.
- No, no, no, it's the peaches, right?
- No, it's olives, it's olives.
- I don't know this.
- I saw another one of like this woman
who had like a deathly
phobia towards peaches.
- Oh, I didn't see that one.
- It's like an Ellen
show and they're like,
"Oh, so you'll definitely
afraid of peaches."
And then she says like
the scientific phobia
word for someone who's afraid of peaches.
And then behind them on the giant screen
is just a picture of a peach.
And this woman just
screams out of the room,
and the audience is laughing.
I'm like, "This is horrible."
She literally just said
she doesn't like peaches.
- I got a clip.
- Mary, you're let go of me.
- No, I can't.
- [TV Host] Bring out the olives.
- [Mary] No.
- That's Joey.
- I just imagine that.
(Joey screaming)
- No, okay.
- Okay, so, finish your
point, finish your point.
- So, my point was, when I
said I don't like a food,
there is very rarely a food
that I will just straight up,
not eat.
Like I said, I don't like a food.
I mean, like, it wouldn't be
my first choice of eating it.
Right?
But if I'm at like a
house party or something,
or like wine and cheese party
and I see some olives there,
I'll fucking eat it
because it comes with the thing, right.
But if someone just gave
me some fucking olives,
and was like, "Eat it
now," and I'll be like-
- I don't know why this makes me so angry,
I have to say this, right.
- No, I mean, it's not my first choice.
It's like, I can live the rest of my life,
not eating it and be completely fine.
- Well, I'd rather eat
olives than most Isekai food.
I think I've realized that.
- Honestly, yeah.
- Really?
- I think now that I've
lived in Japan for a year,
I've kind of come to like,
"Nobody likes Isekai foods."
- It's very limited.
- Williams are crying now.
- I remember when I first moved to Japan,
I thought I would never
get fucking bored of this.
And now two years in, I'm just like,
"Can I have a proper meal please?"
- Yeah, it just kind of suck.
Because sometimes you just want to, like,
you want to eat healthy, but
it's impossible with Isekai.
- Yeah. I mean, I think
before anyone starts the think so
I don't go to like
Isekai every fucking day.
- No, no, no, no.
- No, no, no, no, no.
- I'm also like to the
point now where I'm like,
I could go an entire month
without eating Isekai food,
like easily,
- We have.
- Yeah, but like every now and then,
if I go to Isekai with
some mates, then yeah,
I'll eat the food there.
It's not going be the
greatest meal of my life.
- Because the issue is right.
Let's say you got a
British eating culture.
You have a meal and then
you have the drinks, right.
And I thought, what was
cool about these Isekai
is that there is a whole
eating culture around it.
Where you go to Isekai
you have a meal there,
and you can drink
shocker at the same time.
Until I realized that
most easy kind of food
is just basically snacks.
So, you're having a meal
basically just on like snacks
or like meat.
It's not like a meal, meal,
but it's still enough to fill you up.
I never go to an Isekai and get like,
satisfied with the meal.
It always feels like you just
ate like a bag of like Doritos
or something and that was
like your meal for the day.
That's kind of what it feels like.
- You don't come out of Isekai going,
"I had a great meal."
You come out full.
- Yeah.
You come out full, you
come feeling disgusting,
and you come out like, "Sh, I don't know."
- Yeah. There's so many foods down there.
They're just like, "This is bad."
I don't know what fish it is,
but it's just a toenail.
Like it's literally a toenail.
Like it's the one thing
that Yaki always orders.
- Yeah.
- What is it?
What the fuck are they called?
- The Scaped Fin.
Scaped Fin is it?
- I just call them flat flops.
What are they called?
- The stingrays.
- Stingrays.
- The rays, the rays.
- Yeah, not stingrays.
Just rays.
- Rays.
- Flat flops.
- They are the ones that
fly like this, right?
- They bring this out, right.
It looks like a toenail, right.
- Steve Owen like fucking
rolling in his grave.
- Steve Owen die from
a poisonous flat flop.
- It's like this fucking toenail
ass looking thing, right.
What does it, dry.
- It's dried stingray.
it's dried ray.
- It comes out and you
have it and your like,
it literally tastes like nothing.
It doesn't taste of anything.
- What do you mean? It tastes like fish.
- It doesn't even taste like fish.
It tastes like nothing.
And it's just chewy really hard.
And it's like, why?
Why? Why are they storing it?
- That's most like dried fish snacks here.
- Some are more way
flavorful and nice though.
- Same with like the
shredded fish as well.
- I like the squid, "Squid Game".
- The fried squid.
- It's kind of like a "Squid Game".
- Because you can get a
convening like 20 different
variations of squid.
Squid tastes good. I like squid.
- I like squid.
- It's good.
- Yeah, squid is good.
And then there's another
thing that's like,
I don't know what it is.
It's like octopus.
It's gooey.
- Oh, Takowasa?
- Yeah, that stuff is, oh.
- There's like it's octopus with Wasabi.
You just put it in a blender.
- Oh, it's rough.
Oh, it's rough.
- Yeah, I love it.
- Oh, it's rough.
Oh, it's so rough.
And Joey of course the,
first time I came here
made me fucking eat it.
It's terrible.
- It's great, I love it.
- And then half the menu you look at it,
am not eating this shit.
- Let's talk about fish semen.
Have we talking about fish semen yet?
What's it called again?
- No, it's the sperm sack.
- It's the sperm sack.
- Shirako.
- Yeah, that's awful.
- Yeah, fucking awful.
- I love it.
- And the thing is
every Japanese person will order Shirako
for you to like try out,
but no one is going to tell you what it is
until you take your first bite.
- I'm pretty sure that's
what I did with you too.
- Yeah, exactly.
- It was fucking hilarious.
This episode is sponsored by Manscaped.
- Ho, ho, ho, gentlemen,
the holidays came early here at Manscaped.
- Manscaped just launch new products,
including they're all new
ultra premium TM body wash,
and two in one shampoo and conditioner.
It's time to give yourself,
or somebody who needs it to Garnt.
The gift of beautiful skin, hair,
and balls this holiday season.
So go to Manscaped.com and use this code
Trash Taste for 20% off.
Plus free shipping.
- Giggle balls to the walls fellas,
listen up.
Untrimmed pubes are a thing of the past,
and it's possible you have
Santa's beard in your pants.
If you know what I'm saying.
It's time to leave your significant other,
some cookies and milk at
the bottom of your chimney.
Of course I am talking about
the Manscaped TM performance package 4.0.
Look at this beauty.
- Whoa, damn.
- Inside the performance back to 4.0,
you'll find the signature
lawn mower TM 4.0.
This electric trimmer has propriety,
advanced skin safety and technology
that reduce cuts to your nuts.
- It's also waterproof, so
you can use it in the shower.
It's a great gift for your
partner with less mess.
- So, get 20% off and free
shipping with the code
Trash Taste at manscaped.com.
That's 20% off with free shipping at
manscape.com and use code Trash Taste.
Clean up your nuts and make
Santa's proud this year.
- Thank you to Manscaped for
sponsoring us this episode.
Back to the video.
- I hope Santa use Manscaped.
I prefer anything other
than that sperm sack.
It's not that it's a sperm sack,
is that it tastes like shit.
If sperm sacks tasted
good, I'd chow down on one.
I got no resume.
- He's a Jojo fan.
- His just used to drinking sperm.
- It's practically my job.
- The thing with Shirako.
It's the same thing with me.
It's like, I like it.
- Which fish it from, by the way?
- I couldn't tell you what one of them.
- Who did this?
This is some foods I'm like, "Who? Who?"
- The Japanese.
- Who opened this fish up, saw
like the reproductive organ,
was like, "Bro, are
you going to eat that?"
- Japan is a country that's like,
"Oh, this fish is poisonous, bet."
And then they spend
the next hundreds years
training to eat
the tiny little pod that
tastes like nothing.
Do you like sea urchin?
- Yes.
- I don't like sea urchin, right.
- You don't?
I don't, it's really strong flavor.
- To be fair sea urchin
is like one of the most like-
- It's not strong flavor.
- It's very strong.
- sea urchin is one of the
most polarizing Sushi, I think.
- It's like the Wasabi of fish.
It feels like a gas attack
went off in your mouth.
- Really.
- What are you talking about?
- For me, yeah.
- It's literally called
the butter of the sea.
It's smooth as fuck.
- It is so strong.
- What are you actually talking about?
- I don't think you ate sea urchin.
- I have. I had sea urchin.
- Are you sure just didn't eat Wasabi.
- No, no, no, no.
I had a sea urchin.
- You know you eat the
inside of the sea urchin,
not the outside.
- This is what happened,
is that the reason why I
didn't understand the sea.
- It's like, auh.
I didn't understand what sea urchin was.
I was like, "Why is it
a paste? That's weird."
Until I went to a place
where they like crack
that bad boy open in front
of me and scooped it out.
- Oh, oh.
- Oh, mouth watering right now.
- Connor, I can only
get so erect, come on.
- Again, I had reservations against it.
I'd had sea urchin before.
I wasn't a fan.
It's a cool name.
One of the coolest fishes
names out there in English.
- Sea urchin.
It sounds like some Norse
god, you know what I mean?
It's like, oh, like salmon, I sleep, bro.
Sea urchin.
It's like something died
to make this fish, right.
So, they crack it open.
Again, like with Wasabi,
I don't typically like Wasabi.
It's horseradish.
It's horseradish Wasabi.
I'm not a big fan of it.
When I went to a place
and that gave real Wasabi,
I was like, "Okay, I'll give it a chance."
It was insanely different,
amazing, actually amazing.
If you don't like Wasabi,
try the real stuff.
It's insanely expensive.
But if you get a chance,
I don't know how it, it just came up.
- You're not going to get the chance.
- I don't know how it came up.
It was just in a course and
they just brought it out,
and they were like, you grind it.
I'm like, I don't know what am doing.
- It's very expensive.
- Asked me to grind a diamond.
They crack it open.
They put it on.
I'm like, "okay."
I try it.
It tastes like shit still.
I couldn't enjoy it.
And I wanted to like it so badly.
- What is it that you don't like about it?
I've given sea urchin to bunch of friends
who've come here because I'm like,
whenever friends come over and they say,
"I want to go eat some real Sushi".
I'm like, all right,
but you have to be open
to trying some shit
that you're not going to get.
- Oh, please, yeah.
- Thank you.
- You like sea urchin, Meilyne?
- [Meilyne] I love sea urchin.
I'm like, okay, I'll take
you to a Sushi place,
but you have to be open
to not just trying a
fucking California roll.
Like you have to try like some weird shit.
So, are you prepared for that?
And I always give them sea urchin.
And it's like so far,
I think in my well with
my group of friends,
it's been a 50/50.
Half of them, love it and the other half
say that it's like two fishy.
- I think the problem with sea urchin
is that it's really easy to
get bad quality sea urchin.
- It's notoriously like one of the fish
that can make you like sick and throw up.
It's really easy to get bad quality.
- I've had bad sea urchin before,
and it tastes bad.
But like, if it's like really
good quality sea urchin.
Like the fresher shit.
- Like bad oyster is really bad,
but good oyster is like.
- What I love about-
- Okay, go ahead.
- No, you go ahead, you
can finish what you had.
- What I love about sea
urchin is that it literally,
I don't know how I can describe it,
but it literally feels like
you are eating the sea.
That's kind of what it
feels like to me, right?
- No, no.
- The whole ocean and all.
- I agree.
- The whole of it.
- No, because it's fishy,
but it also has like a salty texture too.
- It's a bit sweet as well.
- It's a little bit sweet.
- It's like really good sea urchin.
It's kind of like downing some sea water,
but it tastes actually nice.
It's really good.
- I've never heard somebody describe it
in such unappetizing way.
- If you could take
the essence of the sea,
and put it into a food
that would be sea urchin.
- That's weird, right?
What his saying, right?
- [Meilyne] No.
- Yeah, see Meilyne agrees.
- Meilyne hears me.
Meilyne is a real one.
- Meilyne is just inclined
to just disagree with me
I think on a professional basis.
When I go to like a Sushi restaurant,
where the Sushi chef.
What is it you call the Sushi chef?
Sushi chef?
- Yeah, Sushi chef.
- Did you master that?
Master Meilyne.
Sushi chef are masters.
When you go to restaurants where,
you can go to the conveyor
belt ones, which are good,
they are too cheap,
pretty easy with the guys.
Or you can go to ones
where it's like a course.
You sit in front of it.
And at lunch menu, it's
only pretty cheap in Japan.
And when I've gone there,
always when sea urchin comes up.
Okay, first of all, I
never ever waste the Sushi,
especially if the guy's right there.
I wouldn't dare be like, "No, I'm okay."
I feel like that is like a sin.
Like you can not look this guy in the eye
who is been there like 20 years.
- I think I'd rather like
slap his wife in the face
that refuse the Sushi, honestly, yeah.
So, like the sea urchin comes out,
and the thing is sometimes
if it's a really small restaurant,
they watch you eat it and they
want to hear you say like,
"Oh, it's amazing."
- That's it's good.
- I don't mind because most of the time,
shit slaps and I'm like,
"Oh, there's another one.
This is a good one. Keep it coming."
- He don't miss.
- Oh, this is good.
- Oh, that macro.
(Connor grunting)
And he's like,
"Bring up the next one. Like I'm ready."
Oh, fuck, oh, it's sea urchin, okay.
All right, well, get the water ready?
Get the green tea ready?
I just like put it all in
one and I'm like, "Mm-hmm."
(Connor speaking in Japanese)
- But most places like that,
they tell you beforehand,
what fish you like and
what fish you don't like.
- Bro, shit going so fast.
I don't even know what
they're saying half the time.
- Okay, so, life hacks for
people coming to Japan.
- I don't even want what's the
sea urchin name in Japanese.
I forgot.
- [Joey and Garnt] Uni.
- Uni, that's it.
- Uni, yeah, yeah.
- Most places that
aren't conveyable Sushi,
and it's like a set course.
The chef will usually, if
it's a good restaurant,
they'll come out and tell you
what fish do you not like,
because they're not
going to fucking waste it
on someone who doesn't like that.
- I'm wasting this man's ingredients.
- So next time just say like, "No uni."
- Part of me is like,
I paid for this course.
I'm eating this.
I don't even give a
fucking if I don't like it.
I'm eating this.
I want to show full appreciation
to this guy and his craft.
Even if I don't like it.
- But you can, by telling them that like,
"I don't know if am
going to eat this fish."
- I just think there
was no bigger compliment
than me being like, "Boss man,
the rest of this food was banging.
If you have faith in this, am eat it."
- If I was a chef, I've
rather you just straight up,
tell me what fish you don't want.
- Maybe am too British.
I don't know, man.
Am too British.
- Rather than sitting
there and watching you go.
- No, I wouldn't dare pull a face, bro.
It's a face. It's mild discomfort
before the moment I put it in my mouth,
it's stone-cold face.
(Connor speaking in Japanese)
- I kind of have that
with Shirako as well?
- Yeah, you got it.
As a British person.
It is not an option to be like,
"I don't want that."
Or like "I don't eat that."
- I remember because
I was in this restaurant.
We missed the fact that
Shirako was part of the course.
It was like this like seven course meal.
- And the sperm sack, right?
Yeah, it was a sperm sack in
the hotel we were staying at.
We missed the part that was Shirako there.
And they put it in front of
us to like with me and Sydney.
And I was just like, "Oh,
oh no, it's this thing."
And Sydney doesn't know what it is.
And I'm just like-
- Let her eat it.
- I'm just like, do I tell her?
Or do I not?
Unfortunately,
I'm a loving partner.
I did tell her.
- No, she's not going to eat it 100%.
- She's not going to eat it.
- Yeah, I thought she was like me, right.
I thought she'd be like, "You know what?
I'll still eat it because
it's Japanese culture.
I want to show respect."
And she's like, "I'm
not fucking eating it."
- I told you.
- Throws the chopsticks on the ground.
Fuck this.
- This is after me
psyching myself up, right.
And, I'm just like, "Okay,
I can deep throat this.
I'm a deep throat this
fucking sperm sack right now.
My favorite Metal Gear Solid character.
- That will be a solid music
playing in this man's ear.
(Connor singing guitar rhythm)
- Garnt just turns to Sydney goes like,
"Call me Deep Throat."
- So, I'm just like,
(Garnt breathing heavily)
I take it.
I like swallow it in one.
- Isn't it like a string?
Like, isn't it like a bunch?
- It's like a bunch, right?
- It's like swallowing a fallopian tube.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's basically what you're swallowing.
- So, it is like a bunch.
I found a way to like
fucking expand my throat.
I channeled all my inner Jojo
fandom at that point, man.
I'm just like, " I'm a
deep throat this in one."
And I fucking did like.
All right. It's done. Sydney.
All right, you do yours.
And she's like, "Have it."
I'm like, "Sydney eat it."
I'm like, "I'm not going
to fucking eat it."
I'm like, "You want to tell the
people I'm going to eat it."
I'm like, "I'm not telling the people.
We're going to finish our fucking food.
We're not going to show disrespect."
She was like, "Do it. You can do it."
And I'm just like, "No,
I'm not going to do it."
And it was just like a game of chicken.
- Sydney, do it.
- Sydney, eat the sperm sack.
Garnt, you eat it.
And then in the end I'm just like,
"Fine. I'll fucking do it."
And on that day, I deep
throated two fish sperm sacks.
- It's a two loads now.
- That's a PV bro.
- And I never want to do it again.
Because you know what?
That shit did not sit
right in my stomach, man.
- But okay. Here's the question though?
Are you the type of person who gets
conceptually grossed out by food?
- No, I don't. Just off the premise alone.
I won't ever have like a
yes or no answer to eating.
- If I never told you ever
that Shirako was sperm.
- It's slimy.
It's too slimy.
I can't do slimy and it's a problem.
- It's too creamy.
It has this really weird after taste.
That is what like set my stomach up.
- Is it creamy, Garnt?
Is it creamy?
It's creamy.
- Yeah.
It was really creamy.
Shirako surprisingly, is
really, really fucking creamy.
- It's creamy.
It's viscous.
It's Sikhye. Yes, yes, yes.
You know what the taste
and the texture of Shirako
is exactly what you think it is.
What can I say, it's creamy,
it's slimy, it's viscous.
- Shirako is the fancy name.
It's fish nut.
- The thing that I have
just realized is my weakness
is slime.
Like anything that's slimy.
I really struggled with.
- You're not the first person though.
- Right.
- Am just saying?
- And I don't know like,
clearly I just haven't been raised to eat
slimy things.
Like I never had slimy things in my life.
I wish I did. I feel
like I've been debugged.
- That's why I don't blame anyone
who doesn't like things like
Okra or Natto or Shirako
anything like that.
Because if you didn't
grow up with that shit.
It's like eating snot.
- So to me,
it is like too close to
the consistency of snot.
And semen.
- We get it, Garnt.
You deep throat.
You deep throat two sperm sacks.
So, when you go to a ryokan, right,
you get a meal, like a
set meal in Japan, right.
You get a lot of food.
I'm going to just call it
like levels, not courses.
It's like level one through three, right.
It's always the most painful.
It's always cold and
it's always slimy food
that counts first.
I don't know why they've done this.
- Not all of it is slimy.
- Okay. Some of it's slimy.
I've been to some places where
they were like, for some reason,
some guy woke up and was like,
"Every meal must have slime."
Like I went to one ryokan,
and I was like every meal.
I was like, I can't wait for the next.
And I wonder what it will be.
Turns out more slime stuff.
And I'm like, "Come on.
I can't get a win man."
But like always there's at least
you get like four little dishes.
Two of them will be cold,
jelly, slimy, guaranteed.
I don't know why.
I don't know why they're obsessed
with putting slimy stuff there.
What's with that?
- Japan is weirdly
obsessed with the jelly.
- They're like a Nickelodeon kid, bro.
It's like, they have more slime than them.
Like I don't understand.
Japanese are the ones who watched
Nickelodeon Guts went
and, "It looks delicious."
- They like seeing this Nickelodeon slim
being poured out, they're like,
"Fuck, they're wasting so much food."
- "Eating it."
Yeah. I don't know.
It's like we do have like very
traditional Japanese foods
are either slimy or gelatinous.
- And it's a shame.
I really want to give it a good go,
and I eat it most of the time,
but with much pain with great difficulty.
- And again,
I absolutely do not blame anyone who
doesn't like that side of Japanese cuisine
because it is a tall hurdle,
especially if you weren't raised on it.
I can confidently say
that I would not like
Natto or Okra or anything
gelatinous or anything like that
if I didn't grow up with it.
It just because yeah,
the first time you put it in your mouth,
it's like, "This
shouldn't be in my mouth."
This should be up someone's nose.
It is like discomforting at times.
- It's weird.
Because it's like
something, am like, "No."
Something grilled, "Okay."
- [Joey] Yeah, exactly.
I mean, I like cold things.
It's just cold slimy things, you know?
- And the only thinks that I don't like.
- What's worse a hot slimy
thing or a cold slimy thing?
- Hot slimy thing.
- What's hot slimy thing?
What is the hot slimy thing dish?
- You put Natto on a microwave.
- That just like accentuates
the fucking smell.
That sounds horrible. Oh my God.
Can you imagine microwaving Natto?
- You do, isn't like Natto
come in microwave packs, right?
- Because it comes frozen.
So you have to microwave.
- [Meilyne] What? You like frozen Natto?
- [Joey and Garnt] What?
- [Meilyne] Frozen Natto?
- Meilyne's angry because
someone bought frozen matter.
- [Meilyne] Disgusting.
- Yeah. That's why I put
it in a microwave Meilyne.
- [Meilyne] You don't microwave it, oh.
- Meilyne is really angry.
Meilyne is really angry at Joey.
- Something has just sent Meilyne off.
- I've never heard of Meilyne
interrupted an episode.
- [Connor And Garnt]
That is the first time.
- I've heard Meilyne interrupted.
If she wants to interrupt,
she'll hold a sign that says, "Incest,"
but microwave Natto,
that's where she draws the line.
- That's where she has to step in,
"I'm a let you finish?"
- Man, fuck, I wish I liked Natto.
- Why?
- I wish I do.
Because it's like healthy food.
- It is extreme health.
- I want to get it on that one.
The thing is that most
of these like gelatinous
or slimy dishes are so goddam healthy
and they have so much good stuff.
I'm like, I wish I could eat this.
- How'd you feel about insects then?
- I feel that's an incest.
- Question to you Connor,
how do you feel about incest?
- Speaking of slimy things.
- Insects,
that water bug smelt vile.
- That's because it was viral.
- I've no qualms about eating it.
Like I'll try it.
- But you didn't try it.
- Yeah. You didn't try it.
- If I had to I'll try it.
I'm not going to like it.
- I'll try it.
- But when Garnt had to do the forfeit,
and I was like, "Let me
try," you didn't try it.
- Am not going to if I don't need to.
- You literally just said,
"If given the opportunity
I will try it."
- If I was in a spot where you're like
"Connor, on this course,
is a the sandwich of locust."
I'm like, "All right, I'm
going give it a shot."
- What's the difference between that,
and someone next to you
having a water bargain.
- Social pressure.
- It might be the only time.
What do you mean?
It's the reason why most
people make most mistakes
in their lives, social pressure.
- Basically it's the British in you
who isn't capable of saying, no.
- 100%.
- And in front of someone
and you'd rather just do
it, even though you're
like uncomfortable.
- Yeah, no, God, no.
I'd rather eat my own toenail
than appear socially awkward
for more than four minutes.
You know what I mean?
It's not even a question in my mind.
There's something about table manners.
I think it's very British, isn't?
I don't know.
- It is very British.
- There's something about
not being rude at the table especially,
like big in my mind that I'm like,
you can not be rude at a table.
- Is that a British thing?
Or is that just like a sensible thing?
- I don't know.
I do because in my head,
like I'm not British,
but I have the exact same thought of like,
don't be rude at the dinner table.
- But like doing things
like correctly as well.
I don't know.
Whenever I meet like
friends parents or stuff,
I'll always make like quadruple sure
I'm like dinner polite.
- I'm like that as well.
- It doesn't matter what
they put on my plate.
If I'm dying, I will eat it just to.
I don't it's a British.
I think it's just common sense.
- I mean, okay.
Say you're at a restaurant
and the waiter is rude
or the waiter makes the wrong order
or something happens in
that restaurant experience
that is unpleasant.
Do you say something to the waiter?
- No.
Do you call management?
- It really depends on how bad it is.
- That's my least favorite thing,
is making a scene in a restaurant.
That is the one thing you
will never catch me on.
- There's nothing that will
make me dislike a person more
than if they have a complaint
that I feel is like completely invalid.
And they're getting the waiter
over to like do something.
- Like, if you're getting the waiter over,
someone better have shit
on your fucking dish.
They'd better be something
wrong with the fucking dish.
- Yeah, I have like a limit.
Like if there's more flies
in my soup than soup,
then yeah I'll obviously
fucking say something.
- You get a meal, there's
a hair on your food.
What are you doing?
- Just take the hair out.
- Yeah, that's what I do.
- Same here.
- Because in my head I'm like,
okay, I'll call the waiter, right.
I'll say to the way that
there's a hair in my soup,
the fucks waiter going to do about it.
Be like, "Oh my bad,
let me get it for you."
- As much as I want to be like okay.
I mean, I wouldn't lie.
It makes me a slightly
uncomfortable, even to think.
And that's part of the dining experience.
- Once you find a hair
and your soup, that's it.
There's no going back.
There's no saving the fact that
there is hair in your soup.
- Calling the waiter isn't
going to make the situation.
- All right, POV another scenario, right?
You're at the dinner table.
Two of you have hair in your food.
Now what?
Both of you tell waiter?
I feel like that ups
the ante a little bit.
- And I'll just look and being like,
"Oh my hair is a little bit longer."
And just making like a joke out of it.
- Also it depends on like
the restaurant, right?
Sometimes you have these kinds of things.
- If am at McDonald's I'll
just buy another burger.
I'm not going to ask them.
- Sometimes you're at a restaurant,
and the restaurant's busy as fuck.
And you're just like, well,
this doesn't excuse it.
But it seems it's going to be more effort
to call someone over
and complain about it.
Than just try and enjoy the fucking meal.
- If it's like an empty restaurant.
And I'm the only one in there.
And there was a hair
on my soup or whatever,
like something horrible happened.
Then maybe I might call the waiter,
because I know that the
waiter is more free.
But if it's a packed restaurant,
I'm not going to be like,
"Oh yeah, stop everything you're doing.
I have a hair on my soup."
I'm not going to do that.
- There are some times, right?
Pretty common mistake.
The waiter get your order wrong.
Now do you say that you,
they got your order wrong
or do you just eat the food,
and be sad that they got your order wrong.
- [Joey and Garnt] It depends.
- Now it depends.
If you waited 15, 20 minutes for the food,
you're like, excuse me, I got
the wrong food, unfortunately.
If you like at some of these
restaurants where you like
there for half an hour to 45
minutes, you're just like,
"I am not waiting another
fucking half an hour."
I'm just going to eat this
food and leave a bad review
and just be done with it.
- Again, that heavily depends for me.
Okay, how different is
this to what I ordered?
If we're talking like $50 steak,
and they bring out a $10
appetizer, that's your meal.
I'm like, "Hold up, hold up."
- But if it's like a $50 steak
versus like a $45 burger,
then I'll be like,
"You know want, maybe I was
in the mood for a burger."
- It's not inherently value.
It's more like, do I
feel like proportionally,
I'm getting something
that I would also enjoy.
And it's also have the same capacity.
If I order the steak or a burger
and you bring out the soup
of the day or whatever,
I'm like, "We are not the same."
- We have a fundamental problem.
- Because also another thing is like,
if are you with a group
of friends as well?
Because sometimes it happens.
Sometimes someone gets
the order wrong, right.
And you have to like,
wait for that guy to also get his order,
and then finish his food.
And then like at that point
you don't enjoy the meal.
Because everyone's sitting there,
staring you to finish your meal
because everyone's already finished.
- Yeah, it's true.
- These are all the things to consider.
- Just read the room and you'll know
if it's right to call the waiter or not.
- The British way is 99% out of 100.
99 out of 100 times,
you don't call it the waiter over.
You just sit down and deal with it.
And then you set the restaurant
on fire afterwards or whatever.
- Easy, just don't go
back to that restaurant.
- Back when you were like single, right.
And if you could go on a date,
did you eat stuff like
wings in front of your date?
Like stuff that gets like a little messy?
- Yeah.
- You would like no fucks given.
- No.
- Okay, I thought so.
- Why?
- I just wanted to make sure.
- Do I seem like a guy
to not eat wings in front of my date?
- No, you seem like you.
- I would.
- You would eat wings.
- I'd eat wings of the
ground in front of my date.
- And be like totally oblivious
to the fact that she's like,
"Wow, he looks like a toddler."
- Do you like me?
Joey is just like bibed up,
like fucking sauce all over.
And Joe's like, "So, what
do you do for a job?"
You strike me as that guy.
- I am that kind of guy.
- We need like a fucking alignment chart
of like trash.
Members of "Trash Taste",
who would eat wings in front of that date?
- I'm like on far end
of the spectrum be like,
"Yes, I would absolutely."
Like, I don't give a fuck who you are.
If I'm in the mood for wings, bro.
I eating fucking wings.
- Like Connor orders,
wings, and doesn't eat it.
So, I'm just going to enjoy the smell.
- At best I would get a
tissue and hold the end of it.
Like a hamster holder,
she's trying to like get the meat off
without making like lip contact.
- Garnt,
breaks out the knife
and fork to eat wings.
- I would try and do that too.
But then I would get frustrated,
and I'd be like tissue time.
We'll get a tissue on
the source on the end,
and am I'll try.
- Meanwhile, the most common courtesy
I'll give to my date is,
I'll give them a word of
warning before hand and be like,
"Can I start eating these
wings? All right. Cheers."
- I feel like I've definitely
had an experience where
I've been eating something
with a knife and fork,
and then I've had like a mental breakdown.
I'm like, "Listen, I'm I can't do this.
I'm just going to do it with my hand.
Are you okay with that?"
It might get a little messy, all right.
I'm doing it fuck you.
- I mean, I'm fine eating my
wings with a knife and fork.
I actually prefer to eat a lot of wings
with knife and fork.
- What?
How can you get in there
and get the the shit off?
- That is like chaos.
- I've perfected the technique. Right?
- Just some anime fucking power move.
What is this?
- I mean, I've been
eating wings all my life.
Sometimes I just don't like
getting my hands dirty.
Especially with like wings
that have a lot of sauce on it.
Right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- You have some wings with
a lot of sauce in there.
You don't get that smell off your fingers.
Even if you like wash it off.
I love that smell.
- It feels sticky. If
you go to the toilet,
you wash your hands with soap,
you all have that like feeling.
- It reminds me of a good time.
- Little sticky fingers.
- That meal was good.
- Fucking hell, disgusting.
When I get a little bit
of sauce on my face.
I'm like, "All right,
now the shackles are off.
There's no holding back."
I'm going all in.
I'm not holding back.
I don't care how much mess
gets on my face anymore.
- I say, if the girl gets put off
by the fact that you got
some wing sauce on your face,
she wasn't right for you to begin with.
- True, true.
- Off your Jojo fantast.
The guy gets put off.
- The best girl will be like,
"I still like him, even
though he's like a animal,"
just saying.
- Find the one that is
right for you gentlemen.
- You know what is weird?
When I'm eating.
Obviously, I was always told
it was rude to put your
elbows on the table.
Is it something you were told as well?
- Yes.
- Is it?
- That's what I was told.
- I wasn't told that.
- Oh my God, Garnt.
- Maybe I was and I just didn't listen.
- If you're eating, like this.
- Yeah, that's rude.
- Oh, I mean, I've just never done that.
- Garnt's like, "I was born civilized."
- I eat with my elbows.
So, I would always like,
what I do is normally,
if I'm meeting with like
a fork or something,
I just like keep my hand
on my lap or something.
- Yes, in Japanese cuisine
you have to put your hand on the table.
- Yeah, I was told in Japan is rude.
It has something to do with like old
back in the day with
concealed weapon or something.
- Put your lap.
- When I eat, right?
I've got my hand like this
and I got my hand down here
under the table on my whatever.
But I was told that it's
rude to do that in Japan.
You have to have your hand like this
while you eat on the table.
- I constantly got told by my mom
to put my hand on my table
Yeah, it goes back to that whole thing
of back in the old age where like,
if you had your hand under the table,
then you could hide a concealed weapon.
And you can just have.
So, when you're eating with someone.
- A modern problem.
- Not a modern problem, obviously,
that's why you'll see in a lot of like,
scenes in anime or Japanese
TV or like old movies,
and stuff like that.
That's why the other hand
they usually holding the
rice ball or holding a bowl,
having their hand on the table
because of that whole tradition.
I don't know why?
It's not really a modern problem nowadays,
but you know.
- Well, it's like having tattoos in Japan,
that are like indicative
of the Yakuza, right?
- Supposedly, even though it
didn't start with the Yakuza.
It started with firefighters.
- What?
- Yeah.
So, when I interviewed
the ex Yakuza member,
obviously, we go onto the
topic of tattoos, right?
Because the guy's
fucking covered in tatts.
And he told me that originally,
firefighters during the Edo
period would get tattooed.
And I was like, why firefighters?
And it's like, so that
if they die in a fire,
it's easy to identify the body.
- Oh my God.
And he's like, they put it in there.
- That took a fucking dark turn.
- Yeah, and I'm like, that
took a fucking dark turn.
But then he put it into
perspective being like,
it's also just a matter of like
you having that tattoo
back in the older days,
that was an honor because that just showed
undying proof that you are doing
a very dangerous job to
save other people's lives.
And for some reason
over the course of time,
with the Yakuza,
and like how you'd get tattooed
when you enter jail and
stuff like that, as a mark
it just slowly turned into
like a negative connotation
to the point where now today,
any Japanese person
with like a fucking
little tiny star tattoo
on the back of their palm
is considered a Yakuza member.
And it's gone to the point where like,
you can't obviously,
hot springs it's like a common one,
but you can't even into like public pools.
You can't go to some
beaches if you have tattoos.
- My gym like I mentioned
is Anytime Fitness, right.
- Yeah. You can't go to gym.
- And the only sign on the wall
that is an English is,
"Dear all international members."
Not even like Japanese.
"Dear all international members,
please cover up any tattoos
that you might be showing."
- And it's weird because,
think about it logically,
just because you have a tattoo,
it doesn't mean that
person is a psychopath
or the Yakuza and all that.
But it's that whole mental image of,
"Oh, they're such a bad person
because they put some ink in their body."
It's this weird stipulation
of tattoo equals Yakuza now.
Which is so dumb,
especially when it comes.
The one I don't understand
is when that same rule
applies to foreign here.
- Yeah, that is kind of odd.
- Yeah.
- And I'm like,
you do realized Yakuza was
like a Japan thing only,
right, guys?
- It say a lot about Japanese society.
- It say a lot about society.
- The absolute state of Japanese society.
- Garnt said this meme wasn't funny,
yet here he is giggling
away to himself saying it.
How the tables have turned.
- We know what this episode
is going to be called now.
- Because we've said it
about 5 million times.
- This is what I'm saying.
The memes that aren't funny,
become funnier the more
you just keep saying it.
"Squid Game", see you just laughed
He just laughed.
- It's pretty funny.
- Like the Yakuza guy was
saying that it's, what?
- He was just laughing at "Squid Game".
- The Yakuza guy was just saying
that he put into like really interesting.
I mean, I asked him like,
what do you think about the
whole light tattoo stigma?
And he was like, "Oh,
it's fucking stupid."
It's like, because the whole
point of a Yakuza tattoo
is we put in tattoos not to show people,
but to conceal it,
it's like a massive difference.
The people who want to show tattoos,
that's got nothing to
do with fucking Yakuza.
Yakuza isn't going to go around,
fucking being like
check out my tatts, bro.
Like, they don't do that.
And until Japanese people understand that,
I don't think the stigma's
ever going to go away.
I'd like to think it's starting to go away
because young people now
in Japan are getting tatts
and they don't give a fucking.
- Do you think the new generation of Japan
are more open to the idea of like,
foreigners and just, things like.
- Very mush so.
- Yeah. It's very much so.
I mean, Japan has been
Americanized for decades now.
Almost centuries now.
But like, I feel it's only just recently
where they look at American
celebrities and singers
who are covered in tatts and they go,
if they can do that,
maybe we can do that too.
Who the knew that maybe
just because you have
a Justin Bieber tattoo, it
doesn't make you a Yakuza member.
- Most of our exposure
to like Japanese society
comes from the older generation, right.
Because they have all
the power in government.
So, I actually have no idea
about what the youths in Japan,
are like thinking and
how much of an effect.
- I mean you walk down,
shinjuku Shibuya anytime
of the day or night.
And you'll see young people
covered in tatts all the time.
Japanese people covered
in tatts all the time.
- I know this is kind of off topic.
I remember like someone told me that
when Avengers came out, right,
and you do press tours.
Apparently it was really
difficult for Robert Downey Jr.
to come here because he had
a criminal record in the US.
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah.
- It's just like, okay.
I mean, I get it.
- But he's not doing it now.
- It just kind of shows that it's like,
there's no room for it.
I think other countries
are similar as well.
If you have a criminal
record, they won't let you in.
but it's just kind of like, yeah.
- Like Japan is definitely
the type of country
where you make one mistake.
You are dead to the world.
- Yeah, it's shocking.
- It doesn't matter how much you do
to try and redeem it
or try and like change your image.
that you're better person
and your a fixed person now.
You make one mistake you're fucked.
- The one thing that is really worrying
is that like a lot of the laws,
and like punishments
was vividly surrounding
like creep crimes I'll say.
- Creep crimes?
- You know like being a Sukebe,
or being a pervert,
or being caught taking
pictures of people in places.
Punishment.
Have you seen how little you have to pay?
Some of them are like $20 fines.
$20, what's the point?
That's a Saturday night out with the boys
if they're going to do that.
- They have so many stalkers here
because they just face no repercussions
for like stalking someone.
- It's because unfortunately
in a lot of cases in Japan,
if it's not physical harm,
that is a result of the crime,
then it's not even considered.
They don't take into consideration that,
you can be mentally scarred for a crime,
and that's still having
real life repercussions
because they just think,
"Oh, but did he touch
you? Did he stab you?
Did he hurt you in any way?
You'll get over it."
It's like, well,
no, because some people
don't fucking get over it.
Like it's pretty fucking traumatizing
for some young women to get creeped on,
getting their photos taken.
Most likely being
leaked on the internet
without them knowing.
And then for the fucking law
system to turn around and go,
"Yeah, you'll get over it."
- Nearly every single Japanese woman
I've spoke to had some horrible experience
of someone being a pervert.
- Nearly every Japanese woman,
and nearly pretty much
every foreign woman as well.
- In Japan.
- Has had a creepy experience.
I'm pretty sure Sydney has some as well.
- Aki definitely had
some and it's horrible.
- It's actually like terrifying.
It's fucked up and I don't
know how to change it
it's not even our country to change.
- But I mean,
it was so weird for me
hearing the first time,
you go to Japan and if
you buy a phone in Japan,
there is no silent option
when you take a picture.
If you buy a phone in Japan,
no matter what handset it is,
if it's a Japanese handsets,
you cannot turn off the
sound of the shutter
when it takes a picture.
- I mean, my phone is that, right.
My phone's on silent right now.
(phone beeps)
It made just like that sound.
- In many ways you hear
about that in isolation,
you think, "" Well, that's
good, you're protecting people,"
but it's like,
what did it take for it
to get to that point,
where we had to then keep the shutter on.
How rampant was it?
The fact that Japan, as far as I know,
is one of the only countries
on earth that has widespread
adoption of female only carts.
- Yeah.
Only during a certain time though.
- Right, right, right.
- Which I feel completely
takes away the point
of a female only cart.
If you ask me, because it's like,
"Oh, then I just have
to avoid these times."
- And am sure in other countries
that women would welcome that.
For it to be done,
and have to be done,
says a lot about society.
Like me personally,
I wouldn't want to raise
a daughter in Japan.
I would be scared to death
of like letting her go
on the train or something.
- I think the other problem as well
is that a lot of the parents here,
and not that I'm trying
to tell Japanese parents
how to be parents,
considering I'm not one myself,
but I think the problem is
that a lot of the parents
also just don't teach their daughters
what to do during those situations, right.
Because I feel like you,
you ask any American
parent or Western parent,
like if their daughter
were to get into a horrible situation,
like teach them some self-defense,
or like trying to defend
themselves in any way that
they possibly can, to make a statement,
and be like,
"I'm not fucking afraid
of you. Like back off."
Right.
In Japan though, they don't do that.
Because there's no repercussions,
even if they get caught.
So, they're just like,
if I just ignore it,
then maybe it'll go away.
But it doesn't.
- If a guy is jacking
off to you on a train,
and you punch him in the face in Japan.
- Then you're the one
that gets into trouble.
- Then you're the asshole because
you're the one who
initiated physical violence.
So, in the eyes of the police,
you're the one who initiated it.
Yeah, it's weird.
- Like you can make the argument of,
"Oh, it's self-defense,"
but then the law will turn around and go,
"Well, he wasn't technically hurting you."
- And also do you have proof
that he was doing these acts?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It's sad, man.
It's really sad.
- There is a fundamental problem.
And just, I don't know.
Like maybe they're
trying to change the law.
Maybe they don't give
a fuck. I don't know.
But either way it's messed up,
and it's more messed up that
again, the parents are not teaching.
- I think there definitely
needs to be more
protection for women here.
It is the thing.
- Women only carts is minimum protection.
- Yeah, exactly.
The fact that we have
to have women only carts
it shouldn't have got to that point.
- And even then it's
not solving the problem.
- That's not a solution.
Pretty much every female I've
talked to has had a story,
has a story now?
- There was a TV show
I was watching and it was
like literally called
Chikan Hunters or something.
And it was literally like a show
where like four undercover
cops would just go on a train.
This is just real cameras
and was like GoPro footage.
But of course, because it's in Japan.
- So, Chris Hans in Japan.
- But of course in Japan, right.
So everything is censored.
You, literally cannot see anything.
Because they're on a train with a GoPro.
Because of Japan they don't
like to show people on TV.
You can't see anything in this train.
They've blurred it out, right.
But to distinguish who the pervert is,
and who the victim is,
they're just blue blurs and a pink blur.
And you can't see what's going on.
It's absolutely shitty TV.
- What channel is this?
- I think it was maybe 3 Tokyo.
- TBS?
- TBS? Don't know which channel it was.
I only really watch like three,
I don't watch NHK.
NHK is boring.
First of all, I was like,
this is a terrible production.
This is awful.
But they found like four dudes doing this
in like one day and
like the same like cart.
And it's like, what the fuck?
They would have to get camera
footage of them doing it,
like multiple times
to prove that it wasn't accident
because they could do the whole bump
and touch some ass.
But they would have to like
catch them multiple times.
And then I didn't know what they did.
I assume they just gave him
like a slap on the wrist
or something,
but they wouldn't show
their face or anything.
And it was just like, you wonder,
well, clearly like this
punishment isn't effective.
Like if you've shamed them for doing it,
would it help a little bit?
But it's also like, is it fair
to ruin someone life over that?
I don't know, probably not, it's weird.
Also there was like 20 cops
for like one dude touching a girl's ass.
I was like, "I think you
don't need this many cops."
- No, I think one, maybe two is enough.
- I think two cops can handle
one pervert.
I think it's okay.
I don't think you need,
like a whole entire.
- The dude is not like 9
ft tall and like 500 lb.
- It's crazy.
- I think one person can handle it.
- It's crazy, right.
So they have the four undercover
detectives on this train,
right.
Then they find the guy, they come out,
and then it was like eight more police,
escorting this one guy.
I get it.
Like yeah, you got to arrest him.
If you want some backup,
I totally understand.
But like how much do you need?
Like, come on.
Like how much tax payer
money is going towards
those 12 dudes arresting that one guy.
- To some of those cops, it's like,
"Oh finally, my first actual job."
- The fine doesn't even cover
his walk from the train
to the train holding room.
Like the police time wasted
doesn't even cover the
fine they gave this dude.
- It's a joke.
- It's fucking stupid as fuck.
I'm sure if we went through UK police,
or any UK laws or Australian laws,
I'm sure we could find another
10,000 million things to criticize about.
But we're in Japan and
this is what's on our mind.
Well, that was a societal
deep conversation.
I just want be dumb.
- This episode did say
a lot about society.
- This one said a lot about how society
is kind of like "Squid Game", huh?
- Who knew that one of
the deepest "Trash Taste"
episodes to date started
with a shitty meme.
That makes no sense.
- It says a lot about society.
- Dear viewers,
do you like it when we talk about
#deep stuff?
- #Deep stuff?
- #Less surface level debates.
Do they enjoy?
- I think #real stuff.
- Yeah, real stuff.
do you like it when we
talk about real stuff?
- I think we have a nice balance now.
We started talking about animes,
talking about food.
- That lasted what? Five minutes?
- I don't know.
I like that "Trash Taste"
is lighthearted and fun,
but sometimes I do like talking about
some things that are not so fun.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I'm human.
- It's an interesting
conversation to have I think.
And especially when done it in.
- We need more people
to talk about society.
- Exactly.
- We need more society.
- Because society is
saying a lot right now.
- You know what else
says a lot about society?
- What?
- Our patience.
Our patience says a lot about society.
- It really says lot of our society
that we have all these
wonderful supporters
supporting the show.
- This guy, this goes hard.
Feel free to screenshot Garnt.
- This guy, he says a lot about society.
- Oh my god, my brain is running, bro.
- Yeah, same here.
Hey, if you'd like to support the show,
then make sure to go to our Patreon page
patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also follow us on Twitter.
Send us your memes on the subreddit.
And if you hate our faces
tell us on Spotify,.
- Bye.
- Bye, now.
Yeah. this was a deep societal talk.
Hopefully, we can have many more
things to say about society.
- We're going to go back into society now,
and hope you guys enjoy
your time in society too.
- Feel free to screenshot.
- Bye.